the GOP has failed to produce the votes
to con to pass the continuing resolution
a government shutdown is imminent so
this is going to be fun and this has a
lot to do with whether or not all of the
spending is done in one single Omnibus
or I'm just gonna I'm gonna defer to you
what is it a single single spending
bills is that what it is yeah single
single subject spending bills there we
go so this is this is really big news
right now and uh and I see a lot of
people already in the chat are cheering
for a shutdown but we'll get into the
finer details there we've got a bunch of
other news Joe Biden apparently is going
to be sending 800 troops to the Border
we've got an emergency Declaration on
the border already because 4 000 illegal
immigrants entered in a single day and
project Veritas is gone so we did talk
about this a little bit yesterday but
now it is confirmed I suppose there's
there's numerous reports now talking
about project Veritas being completely
done with their laying off the last of
their journalists so we got a lot to
talk about lots of breakdown plus uh
some information about what's going on
in Ukraine Poland is gonna be pulling
weapons we're gonna do that before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com click timcast IRL X my Annie
and pick up your tickets to the event in
Miami unfortunately there will be no
Donald Trump Jr he had to uh he had to
cancel because he has a scheduling
conflict but fortunately James O'Keefe
is stepping in instead it's going to be
Patrick Bet David James O'Keefe Matt
Gates Tim pool lukakowski Ian Crossland
plus a bunch of special guests we're
going to have uh pre-show we're gonna
have an after show so we look forward to
seeing you there hope to see you there a
bunch of free stuff the event is
sponsored by Public Square download the
Public Square app we are such big fans
of what they're doing if you want to win
the culture war and help build the
parallel economy download Public Square
right now and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this Channel at
timcasta go to timcast.com click join us
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show for you tonight as we
often do Monday through Thursday where
we will uh take questions and callers
from you in the uh in the audience so uh
support our work directly uh already
joining us tonight you know who we got
we got Matt Gates we got Ami Horowitz
but uh anybody who wants to introduce
himself first go ahead on me
I'm mommy Horowitz what else you want to
know I'm a filmmaker first time in the
show super pumped very excited thanks
for having me absolutely uh glad to have
you we got Matt Gates he's back
congressman from the Florida Panhandle
did you vote for uh to get rid of the
dress code I uh I'm okay with uh keeping
it classy in Congress you know so that
was in the senate in the house
I guess we're still having to not wear
our gym clothes around all right I don't
want to joke around too much Matt thanks
for coming I love you both let's roll
Carter Banks what's happening what's up
guys thrilled to be here uh filling in
for surge for one more night but yeah
let's do this let's jump into the first
story from the New York Times right wing
Rebels block defense bill again rebuking
McCarthy on spending it was the second
time in a week that hard right
Republicans I love that I don't I don't
know what that means had defied speaker
Kevin McCarthy on a spending measure
signaling that the GOP was still far
from agreement on a bill to fund the
government all right let's just start
from the beginning we got Matt Gates
here Matt what's happening
so the government runs out of money at
the end of September and we've known
that for a year and that is the money
that was agreed to with Mitch McConnell
and Nancy Pelosi as part of the massive
Omnibus that most conservatives and I
think most regular folks opposed and uh
we made a commitment in January as part
of the speaker contest that we would not
govern by having one up or down vote on
every disparate agency of government
through continuing resolutions or
Omnibus bills you never get the type of
specific review of anything when you do
that so McCarthy agreed to that here we
are at the end of the month and we've
only passed one of the 12 like single
subject spending bills and that's got a
lot of people concerns McCarthy
initially said well what we really need
to do is pass a continuing resolution
again which you know this country has
been governed by continuing resolution
or Omnibus since the mid 90s
I know Omnibus is when you pack a bunch
of things into one bill and then get
someone but what's a continuing
resolution A continuing resolution is
however things are being funded right
now just fund them the same way next
year with increases for you know
inflation cost of living
so so just keep doing the everything the
way it's always been done is the
definition of a continuing resolution I
do not believe that is a serious and
responsible way to govern and I believe
the reason we have a 32 trillion dollar
debt is because we have governed this
way since the mid 90s so McCarthy wanted
to do that and say well that'll just buy
us time and we'll just do a continuing
resolution for a little bit but don't
worry after that we'll really get our
single subject spending bills in order
I've heard the same for seven
years I've been here and it's always the
same Rhythm and so I got a group of
conservatives together and we said we
will never vote up or down for every
agency of government together ever again
we have to impose discipline on this
process where there is programmatic
analysis and review and a determination
as to what's working and what's not
working and the ability to actually
isolate some of the most weaponized
programs and excise them from the
government budget strategy this is not
just a right-wing idea to your point
like when we were in the speaker contest
fighting for this
no less than AOC went on Rachel Maddow
and said what the Republic what the
freedom caucus what the conservatives
are fighting for here would actually be
good for everyone on The Young Turks
people who loathe me and said they
loathed me said Well if you really think
about it these single subject bills
could help us really evaluate our
priorities as a nation
they even the New York Times ran an
opinion piece Matt Gates is right about
McCarthy breaking those commitments so
in Washington people don't think you
have to live up to your promises they
think you could just kind of
your way through oh you make a promise
it's a few months later you ignore it
you engage in some other power trading
Enterprise we got together and said no
you have to keep your word we're not
voting for these and then today
we add a little bit of a breakthrough
I just left a closed door meeting with
some of the most moderate members from
New York some of the most conservative
members from around the country and they
acknowledged that the votes do not exist
to pass a continuing resolution and they
sat down and said what are the first
four single subject spending bills you'd
like us to consider oh wow and we said
well you know if we're going into a
shutdown let's fund the dod and again
our Appropriations bill has all the
gating to keep money away from the
gender reassignment surgeries and the
dod becoming an abortion travel agency
and all the stuff that that has been
really problematic about the dod second
the Border our Department of Homeland
Security funding bill that that pays the
TSA agents that pays Customs and Border
Patrol that pays ice third uh we want
deep cuts to the Department of State and
foreign Ops we think like an easy place
to show good faith on deep Cuts is four
and eight
because if we're out of money maybe we
should give we should borrow less of it
to give it to other countries
um and and then the final one is the
agriculture Appropriations bill that
that we agreed to to bring up and debate
because there's so much waste in the
food stamps program there's so much
opportunity for savings with work basic
work requirements and we think we can
have deep Cuts there so if you get all
that together put it up get it moving in
single subject review I think you can
build real momentum so the house uh has
a really abandoned the McCarthy CR
strategy today and has embraced the math
gate strategy of single subject spending
bills and that's not to my credit that's
to the credit of some of the moderates
who I think wised up and said well if
we're going to go into a shutdown let's
at least lay out what our priorities are
and by the way it is divided government
so on those single subject bills we're
going to have to negotiate with
Democrats and and I think you know that
is the situation the voters have put us
in but at least we can cast a vision by
passing our bills and then having I
think uh the best posture to negotiate
with the senate in the white house so I
feel I feel more productive today than I
did yesterday when my sole goal was to
kill governing by continuing resolution
I think we've got that pretty well
buried six feet under for now there
there's a threat from moderate
Republicans uh to the gate strategy and
it sort of goes like this well if if we
you know here we are at the End of the
Road Gates wants to spit out all these
single subject bills and we just don't
think there's time now whose fault is
that that's the Speaker of The house's
fault that's the Appropriations chair's
Fault by the way when we were
negotiating this bill last night trying
to get together the Appropriations chair
left to go to a fundraiser
for with lobbyists who is the
Appropriations chair her name is Kay
Granger and she left the meeting where
we were going over funding the
government because she didn't want to
miss uh scooping up checks from
lobbyists is this the first uh time
there's been not there's not been an
Omnibus or a CR in what decades or yeah
I mean this is the first time since I
think 1997. you can check me on that but
but but but to get that here's what we
have to avoid so one of the one of the
bizarre rules of the house is if you
ever have 218 signatures on any piece of
legislation it's do not pass go do not
collect 200 that legislation goes
directly to the floor so all 213
Democrats are willing to sign what's
called a clean continuing resolution
which is no changes to the government
keep funding the woke weaponized
government why wouldn't they this was
the deal that McConnell and Pelosi
initially made they'd continue that
forever under under those terms so
they've got a clean CR and what the
threat is is that five uh you know
liberal or moderate Republicans could
just say we don't want to do the single
subject bills we don't want to go
through the pain of doing the cuts to
foreign aid or to food stamps or
anything like that so we're just gonna
go sign what's called a discharge
petition and then just move that thing
like through it they they
absolutely could and you know to those
Republicans who would want to take that
route I think that's wonderful and Liz
Cheney and Adam kinzinger will will be
there waiting at the bar afterwards when
you retire and never get reelected every
Republican who would sign a discharge
petition with the Democrats will be
signing their own political death
warrant and handing it to their
executioner because it'll be the
Democrats hunting them and taking them
out of office and every one of them will
lose their re-election some would lose
it in a primary someone lose it in a
general but the good news is actually
some of the folks that might otherwise
do that I think have really bought into
my strategy to move single subject
individual spending but it's not even
about a strategy it's about what is
right for this country that we've long
complained all I as far as as long as
I've been uh active in or as long as
I've been an adult dealing with politics
the idea that what do they bring in like
a wagon with all the paper 5000 Pages
they've wheeled it into Congress or
whatever like okay you're voting on this
you can't read it sign it that's insane
and what if you want to vote for the
veterans programs and against the
Department of Education like what if you
want to vote for the military but
against foreign aid they never give you
that opportunity so they just come to
you put it all in front of you and say
well they threaten you with shutdown
politics and then say what are you
you're not a member of the team you want
to hurt the economy or you want to hurt
the country and in the end it's all just
a march to Perdition because because we
we are 32 trillion in debt running up
against two trillion annual deficits at
a time when the global economy is
de-dollarizing yeah this is they call it
a defense bill that is being just that
you were pushing back against that it's
a defense spending Bill like what is it
what else does that entail like how how
long does it take to debate a single
issue if you've taken these things the
defense bill has 186 amendments that's
what it's not a defense bill they call
it a defense you look bad for going
against it well this is no well this
particular bill is just it is a single
subject defense Appropriations bill but
you know there's Amendment sought to
take out the Ukraine money there's
there's amendments where people want
different things to happen with military
policy or with uh mission that relates
to their District or their constituents
and by the way that's what governing
looks like mowing through those
amendments giving them their 10 minutes
of debate each debating all night if we
have to all morning and then let the
votes fall where they may I'm okay with
that what I'm not okay with is a few
people in a back room come up with that
5 000 page Bill and you've got you know
a day or two to figure out whether or
not you're pro-government or
anti-government how lazy and nihilistic
that is so these people these people
don't want to do work that's what I'm
wondering is it just doesn't work so you
mentioned one woman goes off to a dinner
with lobbyists or whatever
yeah she could she couldn't be bothered
to work with us on what should be the
non-defense discretionary number that we
have and how should we consider what
amendments should be voted on or not
voted on she left to go to a lobbyist
fundraiser well so let me ask you what
does this mean what does a government
shutdown mean for the for the average
person I tell you what it means in my
district and the Florida Panhandle means
tens of thousands of people go without a
paycheck who keep our country safe who
are the civil servants doing the highest
end research it means that you know the
weapons that we're testing to ensure
that America holds The High Ground that
that goes on hold it means that that you
know in in an era where 61 percent of of
people in this country are living
paycheck to paycheck that that people
will be you know deeply uncomfortable if
this thing lasts you know more than a
month it shouldn't it shouldn't have to
um I think that we are destined for a a
short shutdown if we can get the and
that's because our speaker was not doing
the work in the spring and in the summer
you know presenting these bills on the
floor for us to work through them over
time but I think that's not a a bug of
the system I think it's a feature I
think the whole goal is to set these
deadlines where we don't do any work and
then at the end you centralize power
with the donor class and the lobbyists
because if they give a lot of money they
don't really they the reason they give
that money is to not have individual
review of their programs it's just to
get the people they give the money to to
make sure that their special interest is
covered by the legislation and if the
donors are going to say the speaker of
the house it's a lot easier to
centralize your lobbying on a single
individual than it is the entirety of
Congress and you heard all my colleagues
during the speaker contest debase
themselves going to the floor saying
Kevin McCarthy has owed the speakership
because of how much money he's raised
and given us that was why that was the
game that was the price many of my
colleagues used that as the centerpiece
of their argument as to why we ought to
vote for him I used it as a centerpiece
of why we shouldn't vote for him because
maybe we shouldn't vote some for someone
who's sold shares of themselves
my idea is that my hope is that the
ideas you have and the way you do things
I hope it's winning
well it's I tell you what we got the
wind at our back and and
we didn't have the buy-in that we have
today from Republican moderates to go
through these bills individually I think
they're coming to realize that is the
only way we're going to get through this
but and I know this is wonky but you
have a very sophisticated audience and I
got some thoughts to share I've been out
in America and I know a little bit about
the tip pool audience but but you know
the the the the circumstances if we do
single subject spending bills and at the
same time have a continuing resolution
that we pass well then I know what the
Senate will do those that swampy
institution will just pick up the
continuing resolution negotiate its
terms and forget about all of the
individual review of programs and and
that is that is unserious that is
unpatriotic
for people who get the opportunity to be
on the board of directors the most
powerful country I I think
I don't know if it's the internet or
whatever the younger generation is more
tuned in to a certain degree
the idea that they would cart in 5000
pages and say we know you're not going
to read it and you can't sign it or else
that's that or else your campaign money
goes away or else your committee
assignments uh could be jeopardized
otherwise your leadership your gavel if
you're a chair or a ranking member on a
committee you could lose that and it got
you got to break it and then that's why
people go home and say you know what I
know that that we're all bankrupt we're
killing the dollar we're destroying the
American dream but I had to vote to keep
everything open because you know our
troops and our veterans I want you
imagine how long the Constitution would
be if it was drafted today oh would you
imagine how many lawyers would have been
involved with writing it amount of money
being spent on it lobbying for it Jesus
yeah you had an interesting question uh
before the show that I wanted to wait on
and you said uh a question about default
do you wanna yeah so look there's a lot
of
um Nuance to any kind of shutdown and
all no shutdown is the same right it all
changes and look my my I have a number
of issues but one of my major issues
when it comes to default is the faith
and credit of the U.S right like we're
the dollar is already under assault
we're having massive issues because of
our economic issues because of inflation
the Dollar's been an assault for a long
time certainly on this Administration my
worry my great worry is a default that's
something I cannot sit with
was it so what's yeah you you asked
earlier I don't want to tell you how do
I mean how long will it take like how
many days it take before we say okay now
we're at the point where we can we have
to start paying our interest rates on
our bonds yeah default of course is
different than the government running
out of money right those the two things
don't align we're we're at no risk of
default because we have abolished the
debt limit we we through the bad debt
deal that McCarthy valade for Democrats
into law through that there is there is
no limit to the amount of fed policy
that can exist to keep printing money
the problem is that money can't go to
deploy to government agencies to run
government programs that are deemed
non-essential during a shutdown but you
can increase the debt if the government
shutdown technically well no there is no
there is no limit to the amount of
dollars we will pay on interest until
January of 2025. that is that is the
feature of the this this is the May the
May deal the the well that's it that's
that's a different
um that's a different feature that's if
the 12 spending bills are not passed by
March
then we do uh fund everything exactly
the same except take a one percent
haircut starting in March and and
McCarthy and the advocates for the the
fiscal responsibility act which was
fiscally irresponsible they would say
but that's a cut in spending we should
celebrate that now government spending
grew by 40 during covet
and a lot of that was through
entitlement programs because eligibility
ballooned but you can't grow government
by 40 and then say that the the
grandiose win we got was a one percent
haircut starting March of 2024. also we
but we I'm sorry oh opportunity cost if
you stop spending one percent on
something that could be making you a two
percent return you're actually losing
money so like just stopping certain
expenditures is not necessarily a good
profit but see that's that's a big
debate we were having today because we
had I had one member look at me and say
well Matt here's here's really where I
can get on board with you if you just
say across the board everyone takes you
know a seven eight percent haircut
everyone gets it this every program gets
it the same I think that's great what I
don't want to do is have to go in and
make value judgments about vertical Cuts
who gets vertical cuts and who doesn't
because I'm really worried that if we
did that there's some Transportation
projects in my district that would be
deemed a boondoggle or wasteful and and
might be cut so it can't be a
merit-based analysis it has to be a
uniform uh reduction wait wait what
because it's not private sector yeah
he's basically saying there's a strong
possibility they're going to find out
that we're wasting money please don't
take our money away well and so long as
everyone's wasteful spending is reduced
by an equal amount and we don't we don't
we don't look at logic or Reason where
my district might do worse that's what I
I I I I I think it's fair to say it's
all nonsensical programs get budget cuts
but it's either all or nothing I I kind
of feel like you should have an
assessment on what we're wasting our
money on and where we should spend it
it's almost like that's our job
to look at the budget and figure out
what works and what doesn't and you're
right if we do uniform cuts across the
board then there could be things that
actually are helpful and are working and
and it might be providing a positive
return that are diminished while at the
same time things that should be totally
zeroed out get to avoid any type of
sincere review I gotta jump to this
story from the post millennial before I
get into the question I have for you
this is uh Ken Paxton reveals Tucker
Carlson that Biden Administration
lawyers were part of his impeachment
investigation in Texas so of course Ken
Paxton interviewed by Tucker even when I
say that he believes 2020 was fraud
that's stopping the ballot counting in
Georgia was so that they can this is
what he said he said they want to see
how many votes they needed there's a lot
of questions around the doj's
involvement in targeting Trump
supporters over the 2020 election and
one of the big conversations that I hear
quite a bit is defund the FBI take away
the funding for the doj if they're going
to be political and Target Trump
supporters with these disproportionate
charges you get a guy you know he gets
he gets a couple years from burning on a
police station and then some other guy
knocks over a barricade gets two decades
I'm curious where the conversation is
right now in Congress around defunding
these law enforcement agencies for the
disproportionate it's Central to the
last 48 hours because the McCarthy CR uh
that that we had to kill was sort of
based on the proposition that by
surrendering every fight that wasn't the
border and picking only the Border fight
that we could isolate an issue that
really you know brought it brought
Republicans like me in concert with Eric
Adams the Democrat mayor of New York uh
I and many others were unwilling to go
along with that tactic precisely because
to surrender the fight at the Department
of Justice and the FBI and the
weaponization that is occurring there
you know is is just not palatable and
it's not just that that stuff you worry
about in that constellation of problems
the federal government has doesn't just
emerge in the doj and the FBI I told you
that the homeland security bill is one
of the ones that's in this this four
Bill package that we're going to begin
to move and there's a lot of concerns
about sisa this these entities at
Homeland Security that do a lot of
domestic surveillance that are uh
evaluating political speech that is
posted on social media that are creating
threat tags around various types of of
First Amendment protected activity so
that's hard work but I'd rather do that
while looking only at the Department of
Homeland Security then do that while
looking at the Department of Homeland
Security and the post office right
so well what's uh what's your position I
mean should there be cuts to the FBI the
doj oh yeah so listen we've got a we're
way past the exacto knife with those
agencies we've got to pull out the meat
cleaver
and and I think that well I think that
really what we've got to do is return
the FBI to a law enforcement uh agency
not a uh an intelligence collection
entity really the communization of the
FBI altered the the perspective of the
FBI they don't look at crimes and try to
catch people committing crimes they try
to become predictive of what's going to
happen in the future and when they
become predictive and then align that
with a really left
leaning turn and then can overlay this
great fear that like the per the Maga
grandmother next door might be a
domestic terrorist that that creates The
Cauldron of weaponization I'm curious as
it has as as we switch into assuming you
switch into single subject spending
bills where Democrats will fall on a lot
of these issues because if you've got if
you've got something in there that has
to do with the program they just aren't
totally indifferent towards right I'm
sure I I you would probably know better
than me but you know I got a super chat
here saying defund to the FBI the ATF
I'm wondering where a lot of Democrats
would fall if someone said hey we want
to provide x amount of dollars to this
agency say you know the FBI CA I'd
imagine someone might just be like I
literally don't care one way or another
and could be swayed to either not
support or support it whereas if you
have an Omnibus they're going to say yes
no matter what right well interestingly
what is defining how the Democrats view
a lot of these things is abortion you
know on the on the defense
Appropriations Bill we have certain
restrictions on how money can be used so
that the Department of Defense isn't an
abortion travel agency and for that and
that alone
every Democrat will vote against the
defense spending Bill I've gone to some
of them and said like this this builds a
new 200 million
District this brings aircraft into your
state or into your community and they
don't give a if they're like they
are so um I would say driven by this
abortion issue that that takes them all
off the bill then the agriculture bill
there's this big debate about these uh
these pills that get mailed out and the
fda's kind of regulation of that is kind
of gets wrapped up into AG FDA so even
even the agriculture Bill they'll find a
way to kind of wrap in with with
abortion so here's what you do whatever
whatever the spending is cut down to in
terms of some way going to abortion
break it up further and then have like
the the you know the minor abortion
funding bill please sign it and it says
this bill allows for the funding of
abortions in your state up to x million
dollars and abolishes the Department of
Education
see now now you've divorced yourself
from the single subjects Paradigm now
you're playing the lock rolling game Tim
right right you've gone establishment on
me well so no but that's the point I
mean if you if if you have to collect
votes on funding for the ATF how many
Democrats are going to be very
enthusiastic about signing a bill to
provide funding to the ATF all of them
because they believe that that you know
gun violence is the great the next great
National Emergency that might justify
locking us all in our homes and and
dictating you know when how we live our
lives but and the ATF is Central to how
how to kind of uh gun scare people into
a real restriction of their Liberties
how many Republicans would be in favor
of not abolishing but defunding to any
degree the ATF I think we have a number
of Republicans who will support you know
some Cuts but let me give you an example
of what we face I had a republican stand
up and say uh one of my concerns is look
we centralize a lot of these FBI people
in Washington DC and they all become
politicians because CNN's taking them to
a Washington Nationals game and you know
ABC he's wanting to back develop a
source so they all become kind of media
politicians so we wanted less of that
going on in DC so they've got a proposal
for a 325 million dollar new facility in
in the DC area and I thought we should
not fund that we should keep them at the
J Edgar Hoover building where they
belong and a republican stood up and
said I won't support taking one dollar
off of that new FBI building because
then we will be the party of defunding
the police
well you're laughing but they they've
already used that line
that's not like a fake thing like their
Democrats have used that line saying the
Republicans the ones Republicans should
say yes
it I I'd be like sure well nobody thinks
that the sisa agent spying on their
Facebook page is the same as the cop who
keeps their neighborhood safe like no no
one actually believes I don't think that
while the Democrats keep saying that I
think the American people are smart
enough to appreciate that distinction
but I I just don't see that as a winning
strategy for Democrats who have
constituents who are angry with policing
in their in their in their districts in
their cities especially as it pertains
to Black lives matter to try and then
shift it to the Republicans or defunding
the police and then all you gotta do is
come out be like well you know the issue
was that we were concerned about the the
lives of our black and brown friends and
family members so yeah that's us next
question and then they're gonna be like
wait wait wait what let them give up one
of their key talking points they raised
what like 100 plus hundreds of millions
of dollars off the concept that police
were bad they don't want to give that
away shift all of their good social
justice activists under Republicans well
this is why they're seeing an erosion in
minority support among the Democrats
they're not stupid isn't that the
driving issue York absolutely well it is
and now oddly enough immigration has
become a driving issue who could have
thought look one of the greatest pieces
of political theater I have seen in my
lifetime is having Greg Abbott and
Florida sending up migrants to Blue
cities and to watch to watch the
application of the blue Mayors is beyond
belief I mean to see the mayor of
Chicago say it's inhumane the 7th of
Chicago I'm like now you see my point
I've been saying that for now for years
I I love the
uh it's just how do you describe it we
all sit here trying our best to be good
stewards of this nation good stewards of
this Earth of humanity and we
politefully and respectfully say hey on
unwatched unregulated illegal
immigrations causing problems for
everybody including the migrants and
they tell you to shut up they call you
racists they call you a bigot and then
we say okay well if you disagree then
this works out we'll send them your way
because you want to help them out and
you don't like the way we run things and
now apoplectic no single issue showed
the hypocrisy of the left than this
right when they jumped up and down and
said New York is a sanctuary City well
until you actually send them to me and
then we're not as sanctuary out of here
well Adam said New York will be
destroyed that's right isn't that all
because of the right to shelter law that
they have like in New York you have a
right the government is obligated to
provide you shelter and that doesn't
exist elsewhere and so by extending
socialism they became a magnet for what
now they claim ails them yeah they tell
that the tens of thousands of homeless
people I see on my streets in Manhattan
every single day who are not being
housed or owned but the best part is
that what they what they try to do is
they try to frame the homelessness issue
as an economic issue not as an issue of
mental illness or drug abuse right
because when they frame it that way
what's their ultimate goal they want to
take down capitalism but they say look
capitalism has led to this this is why
they're homeless not because they're
mentally ill which they all are and this
is what really pisses me off because
I've worked for homeless shelters before
I have dealt with the issue of the
homeless
and guess what why aren't these homeless
people in shelters why aren't they in
homes why aren't they working they don't
want to be and this is exactly what what
my experience was it's the experience of
the people that I worked with they'd say
you go up to one of these individuals
and you say how would you like to have a
room and board and the only there's like
minor restrictions you can't do drugs
they're like no never gonna happen they
want to be out on the streets these
people are often content with having
their you know little their tent and
their mattress where they can go to the
bridge and do whatever they want do
drugs or they're incapable of of
of of supporting themselves but of
course the left says it's an issue of I
I love the line they say did you know
that there are more empty houses than
homeless and I'm like sure but I mean if
you put a mentally unstable individual
who's struggling to wash themselves and
work into a house it's just going to
fall apart around them it's not going to
improve their life you're basically
saying you want to hide the problem but
Democrats will deny that it's a mental
illness or drug problem they literally
will deny it right they'll say no no
that's a small minor this is what
they'll tell you this it's a small
minority of people by the way they all
base it on this one study was done at
UCLA and the study I looked into how
they did the study how was the study
accomplished they literally walked up to
homeless people and they said are you
mentally ill no and they put that no I'm
not kidding that's how the study was
done and they quote that study all day
long yeah well I walked up to a homeless
guy and he had a bottle of red wine and
he was just chugging from it and I was
like you're doing okay man and he went
Saturday morning or something like just
mutter and muttered and said nonsensical
words his face was beat red and and I
was like like I don't know how you
helped this guy if he can't communicate
with you and I mean what was it either
Saturday or the morning it wasn't I was
hoping it was it was a weekday it was
like a Wednesday and we're like we want
to try and figure out we can help these
guys and then and don't get me wrong
I've met homeless people who are totally
of sound mind who are in hard
circumstances but the issues with those
guys is they take help almost
immediately you know I tell the story of
a guy met who was older and he became
homeless he's lost his job these guys
tend to accept the help instantly go to
the shelter and then they're back on
their feet very very quickly you know if
someone finds themselves homeless
chronically homeless right and then you
know where we to go up to someone and
say Hey you really do want a job you
want to get off the streets like please
help me yes we never it's problem solved
but the overall majority were people who
are just like stay away from me and then
they would go between cars and just take
a dump right in the middle there is a
solution and I thought about it a lot
and the solution is and I'm and you know
look I'm for individual rights that's a
big part of of who I am
I think we have to restitutionalize
people I think it's it's to to we have
to build hot we have to spend money I
build hospitals that are warm loving
environments where they can get
treatment and then get help and then get
food
um and we have to force them how do you
oh how do you think sorry to interrupt
yeah but how do you think we'll we'll
not make the same mistake that happened
before at least the situation like the
institution degraded to the point where
people were getting abused pretty
regularly I don't know I wasn't we're
better when I got it better Tech well
right I mean you know the the
opportunities now to have better
oversight better facilities look at the
way prisons have changed in their
construction and how inmates are you
know able to be uh cared for and
observed with fewer staff more cameras
AI technology sensor technology
Communications technology different
types of displays that you have
available so I think that I think that
we're not going to go back to like the
1960s and 70s version of institution
yeah we're not going back to that world
world we could do this in a more
modernized way yeah we could use the
solid it's a solvable problem webcams if
you let people that are in the
institution communicate with their
families they won't feel so isolated
that's a big part of it yeah you can
even have somebody like a therapist
watching the call if you want and they
can be taking notes and they know
they're being watched depending on the
diagnosis sure sure yes it'd be like a
privilege you could earn from good
behavior I think I think the default
should be that you have free
communications I think that should
happen in jail personally free
activities you can come and go from room
as you please and then depending on the
severity of the the suffering of the
individual like if they're if they're
prone to uh like delusions and then
violence then we say okay now we're
going to detain you because you're a
threat to others but for a lot of these
people who are
just let's just say they're not capable
of supporting themselves due to a lack
of cognitive capabilities well you can
come and go from your room as you please
you're a nice individual you're not
causing anyone harm here's board games
here's food but you're off the streets
you're not covered in filth you're not
doing drugs you're not drinking you're
not crapping on the ground and we're
actually trying to help it's more Humane
I know it's it it is laughably absurd
the idea is leave them out to crap in
the streets and that's what San
Francisco is no these people are not
being helped by being left to roam on
their own of their own devices and just
live in the corner of buildings and in
their own ways it's dangerous for other
people too having to step over those
people and if they get hungry if one guy
snaps and he's got a sharp piece of
glass on him you know you gotta are they
just doing drugs man did you you would
think it's a nonpartisan issue but the
reality is we're talking about wet
juices before they use it they want it
because they use it as a wedge issue say
look at the the how horrible or economic
system is today I want to jump to this
story why wouldn't it work as a wedge
issue for like as a Florida man I don't
really understand the homelessness thing
because we have a less of a societal
tolerance for it you know we just tell
people you you can't set up encampments
I mean we do what we can as a state to
be compassionate like you say for those
who want help but you don't see these
things in Florida like you see them in
LA or New York and like I I don't
understand why the argument isn't more
compelling like hey I'll get these I'll
get these people to leave and quality of
life will be better is that too
simplistic I mean they're just we're
just shuffling them off somewhere else I
think we have to find a more sustainable
solution I want to ask you about guys
about this story it's from The
Washington Post from just the other day
Trump hits new poll highs with Black and
Hispanic voters what to make of it
I love the Washington Post I think
they're typically full of crap they say
either former president Donald Trump
standing in the early uh uh 2024 polls
is inflated or we are headed for a
sizable realignment in how non-white
voters cast their ballots multiple polls
in recent weeks have shown Trump
performing historically well among Black
and Hispanic voters and head-to-head
matchups with Biden helping put him neck
and neck with Biden away he rarely was
during the 2020 matchup
so my question is you guys is it true
and if so why
working class blacks and Hispanics
probably are getting hammered by
inflation more than Yuppie whites right
yeah
this affluent white female Liberals are
probably aren't dealing with the cost of
a family meal at a restaurant yeah you
know when the cost of a facial goes up
it's probably uh less impactful to the
family budget than like you know when
when you see prices rising at at the
grocery store at the gas station I think
there's there's tax first of all it
absolutely is true all the polls show
they've showed it consistently
um it's both tactically true and
strategically through and I'll tell you
what I mean by that it's tactically true
in the sense of yes they go day to day
I'm paying more my life is not better
now than it was four years ago from a
tactical perspective they absolutely say
we need to see a change
strategically what I mean by that is
first of all Hispanic people and black
people are just generally culturally
more conservative they always have been
they haven't voted that way because the
Democrats sold them you know magic beans
and said look we'll give you a few
dollars and for that you'll vote for us
and and frankly they they bought into it
I think they're now coming around saying
you know first of all a has not helped
me and B all these cultural issues that
I'm against are another part of the
democratic party that I've been
supporting and I think the more we see
these issues like the you know when
people say the radical trans agenda and
they laugh they go what does that even
mean what that means is pretty simple
stuff like look I don't want to see a
child getting medical uh medically
transitioning right I don't want to see
a kid being take away from their parents
I don't want to see a man uh uh running
against females or swimming against
females like that's what we're taught
simple search stuff have you spoken with
anybody I know you're working on this
stuff you do a lot of men in the street
stuff have you have you done any work
around this yet yes so I are you finding
these cultural issues are coming out in
the conversations I did a video which I
haven't released yet but I'll just the
hell I'll talk about it here spoiler
alert yeah spoiler alert so I I went to
a black community college in LA right
all young educated black kids and I I
said let's play a game I said first of
all how do you identify politically and
every single one said Democrat right
without exception every single one
they're young they're educated and I
think I want to play a game I'm gonna
I'm gonna name the top 10 issues facing
our country today it was trans taxes the
police the Border all these shoes you
think we talk about I'm gonna say I'm
gonna give you the position of each
party but not tell you which party is
which and now you tell me which position
you resonate with the most out of the 25
kids I talk to not a single one
resonated or majority Democrat they were
all majority Republican because the
issues that they care about they just
don't know they don't but they're shy
give us the issue that would be the like
the biggest surprise where they lost
French Republican oh the big you know
what the biggest one was was on
um on uh so on on on giving money to uh
to their Community I think we're talking
we're talking about spending money
preparations and stuff no no no I'm just
talking about handouts in general yeah
welfare and yeah I was like look by the
way that that is the modern incarnation
of reparations yeah like to go and take
these programs that were broadly
available and then to put sort of a a
lens of critical race Theory or you know
uh directing those money to non-white
areas like that is the modern day
reparations that's happening now but you
you say that's you don't think that's a
winning match no no I mean it really
isn't like I said look if you if you see
there has to be an increase in taxes to
pay for more welfare benefits they go I
don't want that
don't want it and when I asked about
that yeah they're not politically voting
they're socially voting yeah
I mean social or cultural it's almost
like they yeah cultural that's what I
mean yeah it's it's it's political
inheritance right I mean that's what
that's what look my parents did it my
grandparents did it
um and there's also an association
frankly republicanism and white right
there's there's all this like cultural
baggage that they have but if you break
down the issues in the black community
this is what you get right and the
Hispanic Community by the way I think
that having their open border policy I
know that ultimately what was the goal
of the democratic party they want to
change like the Browning of America they
thought that would lock in a democratic
majority for generations and they said
that on MSNBC and all these networks and
then it was called The Conspiracy Theory
or white replacement Theory right or
racism but in reality this is probably
the one of the greatest geopolitical
mistakes Democratic parties ever made
because of Hispanics
are very look they're com they're coming
here and what look like well I think
obviously we need to shut down the
border for any illegal immigrants the
reality is the people are coming are
coming from places they're running away
from what communism socialism things
that have destroyed their party they're
not looking to replicate that here
that's a bit there's a big Florida
Energy around that like there are a lot
of Hispanic voters in Florida that are
saying what the Democrats talk about
sounds a lot like what my parents and
grandparents said they fled from right
and we don't want that here let me
propose an alternate Theory
um and just just for the sake of debate
what if it's just that Trump's the one
that's most persecuted what if you have
a lot of like African-American males who
feel like they you know they are subject
to persecution by the white man and they
see Trump getting persecuted by a lot of
white men and they they identify with
that and they're like you know what
they're chasing that guy I I have some I
have some sympathy for him I have some
desire to be Associated look I
yeah it's an argument
I I I would say it's fair to say that
there's probably some of that I don't
think it's a lot I think there's also a
lot of uh you know look man there are
people who like gold chains and gold
toilets and Donald Trump is the king of
the golden toilet that's like he's he's
but he was that in the last election
what you're seeing in this story is that
it's rising that would honestly that
would explain more Trump 2016 because he
was kind of a you know Trump type right
a rap icon you know Max or uh Mac Miller
wrote the the Trump song and uh now I
think he is known basically more by his
time as president and these these
political prosecutions I I you know why
uh you know why that may be let's say
it's true the reason why I don't like
the argument is because
it just it drives me insane every time
Trump gets in front of a microphone and
he talks about the persecution complex
when I I've said it a million times we
all know this the only words out of his
mouth have to be inflation and
immigration that's it that's it because
that is never going to happen
it's a fever dream I get it if if he
just if he just made a video on a rant
where it was like a very you know you
know I got a friend and they can't
afford to buy they go to the grocery
store and they're spending three four
hundred bucks a week everyone's gonna
hear that that's those are the viral
Tick Tock memes where you got these 25
year olds being like here's what we
bought a year ago here's what we bought
today and it's like there's nothing left
there are young people that are upset
about this and Biden's not talking about
it he's praising by Dynamics in a way
it's it's sort of a Tailwind for us
because because people feel it every day
you almost don't have to talk about it
you know I mean you know what people
don't feel every day the debt yep you
know so you kind of have to talk about
it to get people to think about it but I
mean here oh that's that's the hardest
thing man the the no one's no one pays
attention to the spending bill for the
most part no one pays attention to how
the government is is spending money and
what that means for your savings they
don't understand why interest rates are
going up or how it affects them it's
just day to day but then one day they're
like whoa why is my milk 35 cents more
and then some people in my bag it's only
35 cents right and then within a month
or two months now it's a dollar and it's
all related if the government is just
raising the debt limit and spending
money that doesn't exist or printing it
or creating it or fractional reserving
it or whatever then it's devaling all
the currency everyone else has it's
driving up prices and then people they
wonder why it's happening but the one
thing I can say is
I don't think it matters who's in office
when the economy is bad all that matters
of the economy is bad you can make all
the political arguments in the world for
what Biden supports and doesn't support
and he put his name on it the idiot put
his
Who the hell's advising this guy I
couldn't believe it it was shocking he's
like he's trying to handle the election
and we're doing our best to push it back
to him yeah it drives me nuts it is ripe
for the taking let me ask you a quick
Mac ask your question please okay do you
think the Democrats
the the persecution with Trump and this
pushing of trump was in order to get him
the nomination
or do you think they're they're that
smart and devious they thought look the
more we do this the more we get AMU
Horowitz who might not necessarily
support Trump speaking out publicly for
him because it pisses him off like do
you think they're that smart I don't I I
think that there's there's just a blood
lust with him that will not go away
until he is dead and and he will sort of
forever be challenged now you know had
he gone away a matter of speaking yeah
yeah yeah had he gone away and you know
uh played golf at Mar-A-Lago and not
re-entered politics it probably would
have been a lower level persecution you
know making sure he could never get
financing for business deals making sure
he could never uh you know re-engage on
social media platforms but because he
was running again I think there was a a
real bloodlust for utilization of
criminal law well it's it's he is a
comic book villain for them to fundraise
off of
so he's also the he's also the one thing
that unifies their Coalition like what
is the Democratic Coalition without
Donald Trump nothing like they need him
because without like in a weird way
Trump and Biden kind of need each other
yeah right because Trump is able to
contrast directly with Biden on the
economy whereas if you get a Gavin
Newsom it's just you know it's the art
of the imagination and the possible
whereas Biden you have a clear record
run against and I think Biden needs
Trump because this Central argument for
Joe Biden's candidacy is well I'm the
one guy who's beating Trump
I think Joe Biden's gonna drop out so
walk me through walk me through what you
think is the time frame on that and and
the replacement strategy so I don't know
what I should say is I think there is a
high probability whatever that number
may be that Biden is not the nominee in
2024. and for for health reasons or yeah
health reasons okay absolutely
absolutely health reasons
no I don't know because it would seem
with all forward-facing information
everything from the news Joe Biden is
going to run again but they know he
can't win was it 70 some odd percent of
Democrats and all of these polls say
he's too old dude nobody's running
against him there's two ways to run for
office unopposed and terrified and Joe
Biden is functionally unopposed but
they've got to they've got to bring in
Newsome I mean he's he's their only he
Newsome is substantially better for
Democrats than Joe Biden is Joe Biden
recently there was there was a CBS
report I think that said that he's
concerned he won't live long enough that
Hunter Biden's legal troubles were
persist and he may die soon that's his
legal troubles are going to go on for
another 40 years for sure but then you
had Washington Post run a story where
they said a democrat in Ohio outright
claims Joe Biden's death is imminent
because of his old age so when you've
got local Democrats all saying this
guy's not going to last much longer
they certainly have to keep them away
from bicycles he fell off one and stairs
but I mean you've got uh just recently
speaking to the U.N when he said Roger
our institutions and we're just like
what did he say
all it may be the case that Democrats
are just too weak to make the the uh
required stand a statement of everyone
who isn't like all Democrat voters we
all know you are concerned about Biden
South and we are formally asking Joe
Biden to step back and allow a new
candidate to stand to stand we'll have a
primary they need to do that I I I I
just can't imagine
with them knowing all of this with all
of the corporate press saying this and
them even calling Now CNN ran a big
segment about Joe Biden being a liar I'm
like these signs don't indicate a Joe
Biden 2024 they indicate not a Joe Biden
2024. I'll tell you what the problem is
though they have a Kamala Harris problem
it's a significant problem it's true and
the pro the problem is I don't think
it's the way you think I'm gonna say it
the Kamala Harris problem is
they cannot it's not right cannot
replace them skip her over I I
especially a white guy no wait there is
a solution though
AOC Michelle Obama oh you're right will
she I mean she says no I mean you made
more insight than I am we don't hang out
okay I'm surprised I was shocked here
that I'm sorry that I was misinformed
um she decided that she wanted to enter
The Fray I think not only she win the
nomination she wins the election and it
creates by the way probably without even
contesting a primary or a general
because she would simply walk into the
convention Joe Biden would have an
instant medical need to depart and at
the convention it would be viewed as
this kind of dramatic unifying electric
moment she would walk in the Michelle
Obama banners would would go up and and
that would be a uh far more formidable
opponent than Joe Biden if Michelle
Obama decided to run I wouldn't be
surprised if Joe Biden and Joe Biden
said I you know guys I'm getting a
little old for this and no one's better
than Michelle I worked with her you have
my word that that could work Biden
bowing out with Michelle coming in
doesn't negatively impact on that that
what evidence suggests she wants the job
no it doesn't uh and I'm not convinced
that it will be Michelle I think Gavin
Newsom and my so my advice to the Deep
State you would agree that Michelle
Obama would be a tougher general
election candidate than to defeat than
than Gavin Newsom right oh yeah yeah I
think I think if Michelle Obama runs she
wins I don't know how the Rock's dinner
right behind her on the stage there
there are some challenges and I will
stress this okay my opinions change I'm
not saying it's going to be a landslide
or anything for Michelle Obama I'm
saying that it would be very very
difficult to overcome someone who who
doesn't have the negatives of of Barack
because she wasn't the one bombing kids
and uh isn't as active in politics it's
a clean slate high-profile celebrity
personality however but like didn't she
push the fitness thing well yeah and
then get thick well what happened
because she was pushing the let's move
Campaign which was an anti-sugar move
and then they got in and the big sugar
came to her and they're like why don't
you make it an exercise campaign
Michelle and she was like but okay and
then she changed tone to an exercise
thing it was about sugar it was about
getting rid of the sugar industry I
don't I don't see that as being material
to a modern election what I mean what
what's going to happen Trump's going to
come out and be like remember when she
was giving those kids sugar and they
were fat and or whatever and they're
gonna be like who cares who cares so so
but here's what I would say
I think on Celebrity Status in that
respect I don't know what Trump can can
do can do to beat her well I shouldn't
say that I'm probably being a little bit
too hyperbolic what I mean is there is a
possibility that the economy is just too
bad and there's a lot of people who are
like I'm sick of the whiteness Michelle
Obama would have to embrace the
progressive left which is is tanking
Democrats and the left right now if you
look at Bud Light and Target and Disney
and all these companies Disney losing
what like billions of dollars or
whatever on their last 10 releases so
there's real reason to believe that the
cultural moves made by the Democrats are
toxic for the Democratic party and
that's Trump's Advantage right now but
can you just imagine being in the room
when they tell Kamala Harris that
Michelle Obama is entering the race oh
that looks blood I think she wants it
I believe that children
almost every time they shake hands dude
I have never seen somebody more
politically Craven
she was willing to date Willie Brown
what do you mean that's not easy yeah
let me give you my hypothetical so our
viewers all know this one but here's my
hypothetical this is my advice to the
Deep state right obviously Joe Biden's a
liability for the Democratic party the
The Establishment the DNC powerful
interests they need to find a way to get
a better candidate so my my imagined
scenario conspiracy theory is that Joe
Biden is doing a campaign rally in
California has a medical episode
grasps his chest stumbles Falls Gavin
Newsom Runs Out saves the day you think
it's too late to do that it's too late
and B Gavin Newsom was almost recalled
in his own State that's true he smoked
that recall
yes and no at the end he did I'll tell
you what happened yeah he was losing
yeah that recall what happened was was
that Larry Elder was actually making
strides and the so what then what after
Larry Elder pulled at the top of the bum
he was literally about to about to win
that and then the the big money was the
tech money was sitting on the sidelines
the big Tech money said whoa whoa whoa
whoa you're telling me that Larry Elder
might be a replacement then the tech
money flowed in and that's when his
numbers changed he was going to lose
that recall until the tech Bros decided
we're going to weigh in however listen
your record is which you are what your
record says you are this guy beat a
recall Beat It massively in an off-year
election when he'd locked down
Californians now I mean I'm married to a
California and I know this about them
they do not like to be locked down like
you take someone from Minnesota and you
lock them down they're locked down like
eight nine months of the year anyway
right so it's not that big a deal they
got like cool indoor things to do you
take these Californians who like are
used to eating outside and like doing
all these things and you tell them that
they're a lockdown and these people go
crazy and they showed up and voted for
Gavin Newsom anyway there are
restaurants in in Southern California
that are just outside there's like no
roof because the weather is always so
nice
as somebody from California I spent a
lot I spend half my time in California
doing the lockdown dude they were sheep
The Californians were sheep they they
did whatever they were told to do with
the lockdown do you want me to hike
outside I'm not gonna hike outside can't
Surf not gonna surf I can't tell you the
stories I had of I remember I was
walking down the street one time in LA
and I wasn't wearing a mask outside
because I refused to wear a mask outside
look inside people want to wear a mask
I'll wear one outside I just refused to
do it and one what was I heard something
behind me I heard murderer murderer I'm
like where what the hell's going on holy
crap what's going on I see she's face
she's like Instagram live in me she's
like you're killing people by walking
around without a mask look excuse me I
can't I can't hear you
I can't I can't read your lips
I don't know like ultimately the only
thing that seems to make sense is that
the the the corporate press and the
Democrats are outright admitting Biden
can't win well this is my question
because I think that Trump and this is
something that comes up on the show and
God forbid this happens I hope it
doesn't but that he's taken off the
ballot in at least one state because
some guy somebody in some states like he
no he committed a crime I don't want one
then they maybe the legislative maybe
they'll go take it to the Supreme Court
it'll get overturned but it'll be too
late by that point that he because he's
only on the ballot in 49 states he can't
win it's not it's a lost cause I'm
pointing at Vivek it's like let's at
least there's somebody but like I think
what do you guys even think that well
yeah come October next year there's
going to be one state or some
jurisdiction that's got ballots with no
without Trump on them there's no way
that's going to survive review by the
Supreme Court
we have a system of injunctions and like
right people that will resolve that but
it but it doesn't matter okay because if
look what happens in Arizona on Election
Day you get 19-inch bouts on 20 inch
paper or whatever the machines get
jammed up and it happens it's going to
be election day people are going to go
to the polling locations and polling
locations are going to have bouts where
Trump's name is smudged removed or
whatever well guess what we're gonna
need this time that we didn't have left
last time a real legal strategy like
Ronald McDaniel is it did such a bad job
as the head of the RNC and frankly I
wish he was not leading that
organization currently but they were all
interested in promotion and brand
building but there's a certain amount of
like lawyering and being ready to get
those injunctions right then because the
key difference is once you get polluted
ballots intermingled with non-polluted
ballots you're never going to have any
judge in the country that's going to
exercise jurisdiction to go and unwind
them so so let's say in Arizona on
Election Day 2024 not the early votes
not the mail-in votes just the in-person
votes Trump's name is missing
you get your injunction filed what do
they do do they stop the election yes
you go and immediately and join the
election you'll get a court to say that
you are disenfranchising those voters at
that exact time and the election must
must stop my concern is based on what
we've seen with Kerry Lake in particular
with us finding out immediately the
bouts were bunk like the bouts were
wrong and did not work immediately and
then the judges are like nah and now
we're you know we're like a year later
and she's winning these these these
cases they ruled the signature
verification was was being done
illegally right before they're not
winning on the remedies that's what I'm
saying what I'm saying is if if you do
not obtain immediate relief not file a
lawsuit you know you have to go and get
relief
you have to stop the election that's a
big ask of a judge and I don't think
they're gonna yeah but if you don't if
you don't have ballots with someone's
name on it you're presenting a really
severe hypothesis with Carrie Lake I
love Kerry Lake I think more people
intended to vote for Kerry Lake the
nintendent vote for Katie Hobbs and it's
a great travesty she's not Governor but
there were also some self-inflicted
wounds there like you know when I'm
willing to take someone's vote anytime
they're willing to give it to me and
when you drive your voters to one
particular day and one particular vote
method you invite a vulnerability
so the the concern I have I suppose is
it's not so simple as to say we need an
injunction on this election right now
because Trump's name's on the ballot and
then get immediate relief a few problems
how could there be immediate relief we
need to stop the election postpone let's
get an injunction immediately go walk to
the courthouse there's a duty judge
that's on so this means the election
wants to take place a week from now
after we reprint the bouse and get them
fixed however the second thing is and I
don't know if it'll be Arizona that does
this or I think there's a possibility
that happens the Secretary of State then
says we legally and legitimately took
his name off the ballot under the 14th
Amendment so before you get your
injunction we get a chance to argue why
we did it sure well that's an injunction
hearing they'll have like they'll have
like an hour to argue it but but if they
already print the ballots you'll be
arguing day of during the election and
the judge will have to say I nullify
today's results I I it is within the
power of a court to provide that relief
in real time without without uh
arguing something I mean if this is
going to go down
this was this is what already had been
done before the
elections were the Attorney General of
the state is going to be all of a sudden
on the day of election take the name off
I think it's going to be done beforehand
then Arizona
the the the ballots were printed wrong
the files were changed at hundreds of
locations I I don't know how that's
possible unless someone intentionally
goes and manually changes the setting
and I think that was the determination
that all of these uh was a couple
hundred voting voting machine locations
had the wrong ballots for the wrong
machine so I'm arguing the 14th
Amendment argument that they're making
you're not arguing they're taking them
off the ballot because he doesn't
shouldn't qualify I am what I'm saying
is if they can create the bad ballots
and have them ready on election day
without anyone knowing they certainly
can do the same thing and say I didn't
need to inform you that there was a 14th
Amendment I think it would be really
really hard to
maintain the results of an election like
that where someone unilaterally without
notice decides they're going to remove a
candidate's name I agree but in Arizona
they did this they didn't know they
didn't you know I I I understand but the
ballots did not work in the machines
they were made for and that was done
unilaterally at hundreds of locations
disenfranchising voters and the only
argument they have uh in favor of Hobbes
was oh but don't worry nobody nobody
would vote nobody lost their vote
because of it and that's a nebulous
argument you did not count we can't
track those numbers the vote was busted
in in Arizona like you don't think
there's going to be one state that does
okay let's say it's not even taking
Trump's name off the ballot I don't
think so let's say uh New Hampshire the
the ballots uh uh are printed on the
wrong size Whoopsie Daisy and then
they're going to say well too bad you
know we we believe nobody was
disenfranchised from this case closed
and the question is and I'll throw it to
Texas V Pennsylvania in 2020. I was
talking about this earlier it was the
correct decision of Ken Paxton to file
the suit it was the correct decision of
Alito and Thomas to say the Supreme
Court should hear this this this case
but the rest the justices in my view
were probably sitting there being like
I'm not going to be responsible for a
contingent election
there there's gonna I I'm willing to
believe that's exactly right right a
bunch of these judges when it came to
2020 it's not a question of fraud I I
I've never been a big fan of like oh
they bounce printed in China Dominion
the issue was Texas argued that four key
States altered their election rules
outside of the legislature through
Executives or through the Judiciary and
that is not constitutionally allowed and
there needs to be a review on this that
is true and correct if you read the
Constitution the state legislatures have
ultimate say and some of these
legislatures were actually asking Trump
and asking States hey we did not agree
to these terms with universal mail and
voting Etc some did Pennsylvania the GOP
teamed up and they and they made these
changes but the judges just would not
they threw out they threw out all these
things on standing so the merits are
never even heard my fear for 2024 were I
don't I don't know how we have let me
pause I'll put it this way Steven Marsh
I referenced this guy a lot he wrote a
book I think he wrote with Andrew Yang
called the last election and I think
they're making the argument that 2024
could be the last election but if your
argument the argument that he's made on
all these issues would actually indicate
that 2020 was the last election however
based on the perspective of trump
supporters 2016 was the last election
full stop Democrats think Russia
interfered to get Trump elected which
means 2012 was the last real election we
ever had look I I'll tell you my issue
with all these arguments and like it's a
and it's an issue I have there's another
issue I have with Trump is that he keeps
talking about finding the election was
stolen the election was stolen
without having a solution right which
means that what what's to stop the
election being stolen again which look
when this come when this whole thing
doesn't come at the turnout right at the
end of the day what's going to determine
who's gonna win it's gonna be turn out
and all you're doing and this is what
you did frankly with Georgia right you
were just depressing turnout and that's
why we lost Georgia that's why we lost
the Senate and I think it's also had
terrible candidates in Georgia the canis
worked well they I think I think the
fraud narrative helped them one one of
them in particular was terrible but but
the the Heap he look this is a huge
issue that I will never I I just I I
can't look at Trump and say you know I I
take your apology it just he lost the
Senate because he pushed people not to
vote there was uh we had a uh Democrat
politician on the the culture War show
Friday mornings who said I ran ads of
Trump's statements to disenfranchise
Republican voters of course of course I
fully you have to give Georgia credit
because they're alleged legislature came
into session and they do have better
signature verification laws they do have
better ballot custody laws it's not
perfect I don't love the way things are
run in Fulton and DeKalb County but
there's at least more opportunity for
State lawmakers to put those local
jurisdictions into some sort of legal
receivership when they start breaking
the law so there's been some progress in
Georgia we should Champion that I would
I would not be surprised if in 2024 you
have in uh Republican swing state areas
whoops the ballots were smudged for Joe
Biden and then in Democrat areas whoops
the bouts were smudged for Trump
something happening procedurally because
if you look at Arizona as the key
example of this with Kerry Lake I don't
understand how any judge could
reasonably say that election is sound
when the ballots were wrong like I'm
sorry like if you can if I was a judge
someone came to me and said hey the
wrong voucher printed I'm like oh wow we
better have a new election no questions
asked done out out you look at that and
my concern now is why would Republicans
not play the same game and say okay in
the jurisdictions we have more control
over what the secretary of state that we
need to win let's whoopsy Daisy some
ballots and then Democrats will just do
the same thing that happened in Arizona
that goes to a very ugly place my man I
know I agree it's already he can't
resolve these differences through
elections then you know history tells us
that uh it's a it's a far darker place
that people go I don't like the path of
using dirty tactics I think that what
you were saying Ami is that like if we
we should offer Solutions like yeah
maybe the votes were hacked back in the
day if you I've got Clinton Eugene
Curtis testifying in front of Congress
that he built software that flips votes
5149. okay that's on Congressional
testimony knowing that developers can
flip votes 51.49 and you don't see it
makes me wonder that maybe maybe we
should fortify against that maybe we
should start backing up our votes on a
blockchain somewhere somewhere that's
immutable that we can reference so we
don't have to rely on a private
Corporation to tell us what our vote
tallies were yeah let me ask you Matt do
you think there's uh any any uh appetite
among Democrats or any chance they would
support a bill that would make voting
machines code open source uh yes there
are there are Democrats who particularly
look at blockchain as a tool that can be
used in in election integrity and so uh
it's the only one not blockchain I'm
just saying whatever blockchain actually
I was I was answering specifically what
what Ian was saying because there are
folks who believe that that would be a
way to really validate these things and
create a standard for the world the the
code for these machines needs to be
publicly available I don't know that we
can really do that I don't know that we
can go tell someone that they have to
put their make their code open source uh
well I suppose you're right States need
to do it it's not a federal question so
yeah you're I was wrong about that and
you know the other thing is is and this
also pissed me off is I think it was
Megyn Kelly who's interviewing Trump and
she said look the Democrats are ballot
harvesting will you ballot Harvest
there's only one answer to that the
answer is yes yes that's the answer the
answer is not I don't know I don't think
so because you got it was why because he
was upset about harvesting costing the
election last time which by the way
totally understand totally that's part
of the of the part of his conspiracy I
can get I get on with that's not a
conspiracy that's what happened but the
only answer is that's a tactic that look
you were talking about the time that's a
tactic they're using it would be
political malpractice not through the
same thing well Trump did say it was
much like this
when we argue I mean I give a lot of
credit to Charlie Kirk and turning point
because they they have operationalized a
lot of young people to get involved in
getting folks to make their ballot
requests showing back up when that
request is made bring a stamp if you
have to tell somebody to put it in the
mailbox get the ballot put it in the
Dropbox I mean that work is being we're
finally building that infrastructure
it should be the Republican Party doing
that they have failed and so it's a
group like Turning Point dude it's so
important that we open up the voting
voting machine so we can see their
tallying tactics because there's no
greater threat in my opinion to American
the American way of life then
International technocracy and if people
are trying to control our elections on
voting machines behind the scenes like
that is absolute tyranny whether for
good or evil it's tyranny they have
control of our system it has to stop and
maybe completely correct you're saying
it has to begin with the state States
the States run their own elections so
the federal government's not going to
regulate what California or Illinois
does but then you don't want that by the
way right in Florida it was actually the
Democrats who said this technology with
the pimple Chads and The dimple Chads
after the bush V Gore matter they wanted
paper ballots so now in Florida anytime
there's any funny business where people
got concerns about machines or
tabulation there's a requirement for
paper ballots there's a chain of custody
for those paper ballots there are
retention requirements for those paper
ballots and it's led to a to a pretty
high functioning system
oh that's good I still I this is why
people gotta vote vote locally and and
too many people look to federal
government to solve problems that
federal government cannot solve can you
guys from the federal government issue
like suggestions to States well here's
an idea uh back when school choice was
really emerging in the thought space of
conservatism you Congress was looking to
get involved but we believed education
was primarily a state function but there
is one place that we have exclusive
jurisdiction and it's Washington DC and
so Congress did DC education vouchers
they drove down the cost they increased
the quality and then that became a model
for places like Florida where we've
expanded school choice so one idea is
that you take whatever is the gold
standard for elections on signature
verification election day voting voter
ID not letting illegal aliens vote you
know uh all the Jim Crow stuff yeah
right right apparently take all that
stuff and say these are the new election
laws for Washington D.C and there you're
you're putting it over an overlay of a
primarily Democrat uh area but you could
model that and see if it was replicated
so like a blockchain backup system like
seven blockchains where everything's you
can go high-tech or low-tech you know
our paper ballots better than blockchain
I think it's a reasonable debate but but
we could actually design a model system
uh without violating our concepts of
federalism yeah I think it would be both
paper and backed up on a blockchain so
you could reference the two who would
have to put that in order it would be
Congress yeah we have a committee the
house administration committee that has
jurisdiction over this and it's
precisely what the chairman told me he's
working on an Ideal election Integrity
bill for Washington D.C that that we
hope would uh would draw favor elsewhere
we got to talk about the border so we
got this story from the hill Biden
Administration sending 800 new troops to
border amid migrant crisis we also have
the uh Texas governor Greg Abbott
declaring an invasion he previously
declared an invasion he was just
reiterating that he had declared an
invasion and we recently learned that
the town of city of Eagle Pass I believe
the town uh declared an emergency four
thousand pirates in a single day
I got a lot of questions it does feel
perfect political timing all of a sudden
this news is back in in place the
election's coming up and now we're
getting big news about this why why is
is this like a legitimate Spike that's
just happening right now or has this
been going on for the past you know two
three years
cool go ahead on me I mean as somebody
who's who's been uh who traveled with a
number of the Caravans come up here no
it's going on for a while and when you
ask them why are you coming up now they
will tell you because Biden is president
this is what they'll tell you this is
what they told me I mean this is it this
could not be more obvious I mean just
look at the statistics when Trump was
President versus Biden right I mean this
is not debatable well they have those
shirts that like what is that please let
us in Biden or something like that those
yeah despite the Democrats living in
their alternative reality where they say
the border is closed we've closed the
border right isn't that what they say
all all day long I reckon yeah there's
there's a video where it looks like
border patrol agents open the gates let
them in and count them and then close it
and these are these are like African
migrants coming in that are being
welcomed in by U.S border Patrol they're
not protecting our borders they're
shooting
up the boys
on the U.S side how dare we what are we
doing here what are we doing I look at
the end of the day they they still
believe despite what we talked about
before where they're making a mistake in
terms of how this is going to work out
generationally for them they still think
this is the best tactic to lock in
generational Democratic votes by letting
everybody in look I did a video I did a
video one time where I walked around and
I asked the left and I said is having a
border racist and they all said yes it's
racist to have a border because you're
not allowing brown people into the
country now ironically when I went
across the border and I asked the
migrants is it wrong for America to have
a border they go no were you crazy like
I want to be here you need to try to
stop me like they get it take a look at
this story from the New York Post Biden
secretly has let 221 456 migrants fly
into the US in the past year how is it
that we're getting a story that is
sending troops to the Border but he's
also letting them all come in it sounds
like it's fake news like or it's just
it's a virtual signal it's a virtue
signal because they're getting hammered
by Eric Adams and hocal and a lot of
these uh Sanctuary City jurisdiction
left-leaning politicians and they are
they are in need of some sort of gesture
that they can point to that they've been
heard but you don't need to look any
farther than the cbp1 app that our own
Department of Homeland Security
developed to ensure that there was a
orderly and appropriate passageway for
people into our country without too much
paperwork and it was immediately hacked
by the cartels and totally utilized by
the cartels to move their own people
into the country so we literally built
an app for the cartels
so that there wouldn't be too much you
know bureaucratic uh bureaucratic
challenge for them so long was it hacked
before they realized it had been hacked
oh I mean it was it was within a matter
of week wow and they were just being
used to like organize yeah well the
cartel would wall off any any any claims
that weren't the claims into the system
that they had managed controlled and and
monetized what's what's the Florida
sentiment right I know there's a lot of
uh Cubans and Venezuelans who escaped
communism and they come to Florida and
we also know that Florida has a huge
swing towards Republicans in the past
election cycle I'm curious like what's
what's it like on the ground for regular
people how do they feel about the
illegal immigration well it turns out in
Florida we actually have enough people
coming to our state just from other
states within the United States you know
we we've got the uh migrants from uh
Illinois and uh New York and California
uh there there is a new law that
Governor DeSantis and our legislature
put into effect that creates
consequences for people and that ensures
that people are held until the ice
detainers are executed on uh and it's
not just going to be released into our
community and we've actually had a lot
of successful self-deport station in
recent months in Florida where people
who are there illegally are getting up
and leaving I know that because I've had
construction companies and lawn care
companies called me and say what the
heck this this new law in our state is
causing all my workers to leave and
there will be some short-term pain when
we ultimately reshape our economy around
the American Experience not just
exploiting people who come here that you
can pay under the table it's the drugs
man it's the it's the figurative
economic drugs of they they want cheap
labor to come in but then they create
industry that becomes dependent upon it
and then you become the bad guy for
trying to solve the problem
you say we got it we got to deal with
illegal immigration and all of a sudden
oh no I'm losing my my cheap under the
table workers it's your fault I don't I
don't remember I mean there's kids in
cages now but I don't recall
um AOC drifting in crying wearing white
like a bartending Specter crying about
keeping kids in cages in the last couple
years
it's called Uh because when it was
Donald Trump we had cages for for these
children and children were put in cages
but as soon as uh Biden came in we
replaced the cages in name and now we
call them safety facilities that's right
yeah but the word safety say yes once
you use the word safety that means you
can do anything you want don't tell
McCarthy it'll be the safety continuing
resolution
or the Patriot continuing resolution and
by the way one of the games
I've now seen the people on the left
doing and is that they go well we we
send them into the interior of the
country but the majority of people come
back for their court case now by the way
technically that's true but the reason
why that's true is because they know you
get two right the first one they come
back for because I know they get an
appeal they never come back for the
second one they come back but they never
they'd left never mentioned the second
one they only mentioned the first one
statistically because they're right
because that's the argument now no no no
no you can let them in they all come
back for their court case
unreal it's the it's the it's very dark
in my mind when I think about excessive
immigration what it's done to countries
in the past what it's done to empires in
the past when it did to Rome are we all
thinking about the Romans hyper
accelerated the fall of the Empire like
no I was thinking of the UK
what what's the status yeah in the UK
what immigration has done to that
country has been devastating to their
economy to their social experience it's
been rough France not much better
Germany am I much better Sweden
Nordic socialist economies all the all
the folks that were displaced from the
wars in the Middle East ended up working
their way kind of up up uh through
Europe and into those benefit structures
the funny thing about the the
Scandinavian countries is how Norway was
a bit more based and Sweden was a bit
more woke Norway was like we will
absolutely release all the stats on
crime demographics age Etc Sweden was
like we're not going to do that and you
so what would happen is people in Sweden
would look at Norway because it's
extremely comparable and be like yeah we
know our government's lying to us in
Denmark when you're trying to get on the
train to Mama you got to give you you
got to give your ID because they're very
concerned it's the it's the Danish
they're super concerned about what's
going on Sweden I don't care so Sweden
used to when they released the crime
statistics they did release the
demographics of the crime statistics
they stopped doing right
yep I'm looking at the lamp that Italian
island that's been overrun by Tunisian
migrants like 13 000 tunisians just
around this island of 6 000 people or
something Francis said yesterday they're
not going to welcome the migrants that
are in lampedusa uh Poland accused the
EU of encouraging human trafficking for
allowing this to happen
um they are the traffickers kick them
off the uh off uh Tunisia off the coast
and then it's uh it's military and and
uh ngos that come pick them up it's all
human trafficking so when I I actually
went on the raft with the Syrian uh
migrants from Turkey to Greece wow how
long was that at that super short right
it might be three hours you could see
let's see Greece yeah you can see Greece
when you take off I watch people swim
you're in my crazy yeah we have very
different type of trips to the
Mediterranean I remember when I when I
was having a discussion my first you
know because people were dying on this
trip oh so I had a conversation with the
um with the Coast Guard New York coast
guard I said I need a little bit of
advice and they go one I go well I need
to know what it's like if I'm going on
this rafting trip across the ocean
across the the the uh Adriatic to to
Greece they go okay you're kidding
around I'm like no I'm serious they go
okay here's the things that you need so
I needed a a type 2 life jacket makes
sense the kind of thing if you lose
Consciousness it keeps you your face up
you needed a strobe light also made
sense you know in case you're in the
thing
um you need a flare gun took all these
things made total sense then they said
you need a uh a knife so I said okay I'm
assuming that's because if I get caught
in the rigging I can cut myself no no no
he's like they're all going to try to
steal your life jacket and you have to
stab your way out of it wow and he goes
and the one last thing you need you
ready for this condoms I go look man I'm
a red-blooded American but I think I
could hold myself on a three hour rap
product no no if you do lose your life
jacket if you blow up condoms and put
them under your arm it'll give you maybe
10-15 minutes of extra time
so uh check out this map you want to
pull this up Carter this is uh this is
Greece and uh this is lesvos you can see
it's it's it's super close to Turkey
so all the migrants are coming here
there's migrant camps and then that's
Greece so once you're in Greece there's
a ferry that goes straight to Athens
but you're as you're talking about it's
all trafficking for me to get on this
raft I had to deal with the Turkish
Mafia yeah they controlled the entire
thing and by the way it's not cheap
that was a it was 2 000 Euros if you're
a migrant to get to let to get a seat on
this thing I don't like I don't even
know where they're coming
I'll tell you I interviewed I've
interviewed two brothers who uh one
brother left before the war got really
bad went to Romania and got uh I don't
know if we got citizenship he got like
uh he got a refugee status so it allowed
him travel to the Schengen Zone allowed
him to work and he was living a good
life doing uh computer graphic design
stuff his brother stayed behind then
eventually Europe closes it closes off
saying like no we can't take any more
refugees so he tries to get on a raft
from Izmir to lesvos and he's a he's a
young man who has money and works he
saves it up this is not so I mean this
is someone fleeing War for sure but they
have money it's not like it's just
people living in but they're not they're
not see here's the thing they're not
fleeing War well this guy they're not
going from Syria they're going from
Turkey they're already once they're in
Turkey you're saying right you're
definitely more anymore right right now
we're just talking about I want an
upgrade on my life conditions right
that's the only issue they're not
leaving from Syria to get away they're
already safe physically in Turkey I
completely agree because in a way to
leverage the west and the EU has been
pretty masterful right whenever he seeks
some concession you know he threatens to
have some massive release out of turkey
and uh whenever he gets what he wants
he'll sort of constrain those releases
and so it's become a geopolitical he's a
weapon he's weaponized it for sure I've
destroyed his own economy but yeah he's
weaponize that I've heard the excuse
that people are fleeing economic tyranny
I don't know how to describe it they're
like their economic uh refugees like
dude that doesn't exist bro that's not
how it works that's why every person has
pretty much come to the United States uh
over the last 50 years and we used to
call those people illegal aliens and now
we call them economic refugees but why
but why right the question why are they
using that language they're using it
very specifically it is all the game is
the destruction of our capitalist system
that's the game and the more you use the
word economy economy it's because of
money it's money it's because they're
saying look your system is what put them
there we have to raise the entire thing
and start over again with the Socialist
structure and if it wasn't the economy
it was climate change right yeah yes
right like so intra I don't want to get
off topic but you brought it up so
interesting the way zelinski in his
speech mentioned climate change so often
and by the way I'm a supporter of
Ukraine and it's it's it's the fight
against Russia how much have you given
well so let's let's uh let's pull the
story I'll pay a lot of taxes let's pull
this we'll pull this door up and we'll
jump in sorry about that here we go from
timcast.com intelligence official quote
Russia has already won White House media
are lying about Ukraine
the explosive claim was made in the
latest bombshell report published on
September 21st by Pulitzer Prize Wing
investigative reporter Seymour Hersh who
spoke with an official who has access to
current intelligence intelligence about
the conflict the wars over Russia's
wanted by the court already according to
Hershey's report the war is continuing
because Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski insists that it must currently
there is no discussion at zelenski's
headquarters or at the White House about
a ceasefire and no interest in
discussions that could lead to an end of
the conflict so I suppose we could just
say right now see Maurice is wrong and
his source is bad but I'm curious what
you guys think about where we're what's
currently going on where we are with
Ukraine and you were going to make a
point before I interrupted you uh about
uh the war in Ukraine uh so so yeah the
reason why
um yeah I'm going to see him rehearse in
a second but the reason why he's using
the language of climate change and the
reason why they now have a trans person
is a military spokesperson that's going
well and uh he was put on leave oh he
was okay yeah uh because he stole
somebody's luggage no no he said that
everyone who spoke out against the
government needed to be jailed and then
they went and arrested guns uh Gonzalo
Lira and uh have been Gonzalo reported
torturing him yeah they were threatening
that anyone that spoke poorly of Ukraine
would be facing like justice and it's
like why are you threatening U.S
citizens that spoke about against
Ukraine and they're torturing one right
now
so a couple days ago there put on leave
I don't know much more about it that's
what I heard anyway starting around I
was saying that they look they know they
know that they are um look where's their
bread buttered it's by Administration
yep all he hears Biden saying is climb
the clan climate change climate change
so hey hell why don't I make climate
change the issue here and I'll get even
worse it's really low brow a really
pathetic attempt to manipulate I'm very
concerned about this but I think it
works I think the left looks that I go
oh he's for he uh it's a signal what
he's saying to the the elite left is I'm
willing to read the script it's a signal
to them that I'm your boy I'll read this
one climate change trans what's the next
thing you guys need just keep the money
flowing these are all signals for that
That explicit purpose I'm not going to
get into like who's winning or losing
the war because I'm on the armed
services committee and don't want to
reflect on anything classified but I
think we can look at Afghanistan and we
can look at what's going on here and say
what a lot of these defense contractors
are pushing toward is how to have an
extended kind of low-yield War like if
there's a way to stretch this thing out
turn it into a 20 30 year kind of thing
where there's a whole lot of money
moving around and unaccountable pots and
a lot of weapons getting bought and then
oh man the stockpiles well we got to
spend more money to reload those
I think that the reason we are as
involved in Ukraine as we are is because
Afghanistan wound down and if we still
had Afghanistan to launder money through
there probably wouldn't be the need for
this type of excessive involvement in
Ukraine dude I would love to alter our
weapons program to create just a drone
defense program where we go up into
space in low orbit and we just build
billions of drones that we blow up and
we give the defense companies all this
money even more money than they're
making now to blow up machines instead
of humans and then we can work with
Russia that rant from Ian Crossland was
brought to you by Raytheon
my jacket offs I know we're going two on
one here and I'm good two on one
what about him three on one
I'm an innocent sideliner what are you
thinking
well the idea that we would just give
money the military industrial complex to
appease them to Abate them because they
do bad things it's kind of like it's a
parasite in my brain and I don't know
how to get rid without killing myself so
I don't want to kill myself uh and I
admit that military is a big part of our
the ethos of the United States I mean
we're a militaristic country on your
foot keep it away from your pancreas
well just I just want to remind you the
language we're using and look it's okay
but it's the language the Left Right the
left has always been the ones talking
about the military industrial complex
and that's what runs our country and and
I'm not saying you're the one thing they
were right about I'm not saying you
can't say it yeah great leftist thinker
Dwight D Eisenhower but I think they
were they I think the left 10 13 years
ago was right about a whole lot they
supported Julian Assange now all of a
sudden they're in line with Amazon
Walmart and major corporations for free
speech and they oppose government
surveillance yeah now they're in favor
of censorship yeah the military used to
be racist now they're for NATO expansion
they used to be opposed to uh defunding
the police and also entities are using
it against Republicans I drank with
Julian Assange while I was in her house
arrest in London oh wow what did you
drink
scotch okay come on single mode Blended
what am I a trogadite of course a single
mom okay just checking I used to be I I
look at this report it's funny that this
Tim Cass just published this it's uh I
believe agent Adrian Norman is reporting
on it because uh I said this a little
while ago and we were talking downstairs
before the show I was talking to Ami and
I said so we have this map from the BBC
and you can look at February 22 uh 2022
you've got separatist back Don bass and
then you have Crimea underbrushing
control and then by June 2023 Russia
controls the entire land bridge into
Crimea and so they they won They seized
the territory they wanted to gain
control and more access to their their
uh warm water port in the in the Black
Sea and their access to the
Mediterranean so first of all Seymour
Hersh is not a credible Source right I
mean sometimes something he says is
credible you don't know you don't buy
the bin Laden see more her story no not
an argument though so so I could say I
understand the New York Times insert all
the wrong things everything that was
wrong about all the military stuff but I
agree with you we don't have to just
blindly agree this story is true so I'm
looking I only look at this through the
prism of what's good for the United
States ultimately right what is good in
our what is in our national interest it
is in our national interest to continue
to degrade the Russian military taking
Russia off the geopolitical board which
is what we are in the process of doing
and taking them off that board for 25 or
30 years is in our national interests to
destroy them economically by losing
their entire European access the gas
market is in our economic interest and
even more than that what's our what's
really our interest taking time Taiwan
off the table in terms of a Chinese
Invasion and I'm telling you this is
what we've done China has looked at
Ukraine understanding it is not in the
U.S national interest anywhere close to
what Taiwan is and we went to bat for
Ukraine they understand that if they
invade Taiwan they are
screwed they will not invade Taiwan for
the next 25 years they technically did
several but like we're talking about
land Invasion because four days ago
we've had Jerusalem Post saying China
invades Taiwanese airspace with 20
military aircraft a week before that
there was something like 60 different
ships they're flying stories over Taiwan
all the time right so that answer would
absolutely get an A at the Georgetown
School of Foreign Service right that
that is the that is the answer that we
hear most frequently so I want to take
some of those arguments first that we
have to take Russia off the geopolitical
landscape so since the invasion they
have actually got more relationships in
Africa not less Putin just hosted this
big African Summit where the they all
came to Moscow and he was able to make
even even more audacious claims of
support and Grain and by taking you know
by taking Ukraine out of the
distribution of some of that grain he's
stepping in to fill it so in a way the
war in Ukraine is allowing him to
project more power in Africa please
please that that's the argument the afro
who cares by the way I care way more
about the Essential Elements and The
Rare Earth elements that drive the
entire global economy that exist in
Africa that I care about some oil rigs
in the dumbass rare you know the Rare
Earth elements aren't rare we can we can
mine and they're in Alaska they can buy
them here but because of Biden but what
is but what's more geopolitically
important the dumbbells or Africa then
what do I care more it's not about Don
bass what do I care more about Africa we
have driven Sweden and Norway into NATO
which they didn't do for decades and
decades that's when they've done not now
we now we've provided we've extended the
security guarantee to two more countries
two two more two more very stable
countries who by the way are an absolute
interest to defend by the way I am not
for Ukraine being part of NATO I'm not
for Ukraine being part of the EU for
those Reasons I'm not looking to have I
do not want to have any I don't want a
U.S troop in Ukraine and I wouldn't
support anything that would
contractually obligate us do that but
for Sweden Norway to have them come into
NATO is a huge win for us us because
there are two more countries that now
are are protectorates of the United
States there are two more people that
that have armies well let's see when
they actually meet the requirements on
their military spending and and and and
by the way we this is also helped put
yeah look I again I agree completely I
think it is a is an embarrassment that
they haven't I think we should and I
think I'm glad and by the way they
increased their they increased their
spending because of Trump trump pushed
the nuclear spending because he said it
will pull out and they said whoa but by
the way they have spent more money on
Ukraine than we have I'm glad that at
least uh Sweden and Norway than we have
all of Europe okay well you know since
Ukraine's in Europe it seems reasonable
okay what I'm saying is they we have now
found a way to get them to spend more
money on the military and I think they
realize this was 118 billion that's a
you know what is that all it is so far
118 I thought it was important that's
what we got on paper yeah I mean you
know seems Seems like a lot to me I also
want to address the Taiwan argument
because I think the major geopolitical
objective we ought to have is to stop a
fusion of China and Russia the the
sino-russian alliance poses a greater
threat to us than almost anything and
through our involvement in this war we
have driven Russia into the arms of
China you look at a lot of the Farmland
in Eastern Russia it is getting bought
literally bought by the Chinese you're
seeing a leveraged buyout of Russia
through China that is making them
stronger and I don't think that she
views donbass in Ukraine as in any way
like comparable tactically to the home
game that they get to play in Taiwan I
mean it's not a surprise to anyone that
when we war game out a Taiwan conflict
China wins every time why because our
f-35s don't get into the fight our
littoral combat ship gets blown up
before they even get there and we run
out of torpedoes that's what happens in
every in every war game and I don't know
that that type of a like Maritime
amphibious assault is comparable to
Putin running some broken tanks into you
into Ukraine and when it comes to
degrading the Russian military I worry
more about Russia's nuclear weapons than
I worry about what tanks and armored
divisions they have rolling around the
plains of Europe I don't think my
Constitution I don't think my
constituents are fundamentally impacted
based on which guy in a track suit is in
charge of Crimea yeah I do think they're
impacted if we are like poking the
nuclear bear
and I do believe that uh it is well
within within the capabilities of Putin
to use nuclear weapons I am not saying
murves or you know the Satan II missile
they call it I'm talking about you know
100 kiloton nuclear artillery things
like that being launched into
Battlefield why do you take the merving
armaments off the table so oh I'm not
I'm saying the first thing we should we
should be concerned about is in the
active theater in eastern UK false flag
no no I'm saying don't yes that's a big
factor as well but uh honestly there's a
good argument to be made that it is more
reasonable that Ukraine would false flag
a nuclear strike to blame Russia but
there's also very good reasons for
Russia if they want to expand their
territory Beyond just the land bridge
why do you think they would do that why
would Russia use you know what you think
you could I mean look I'm not I don't
know I'm not in the mind of the
ukrainians oh I'll give you okay it's
really simple if you're a Ukrainian if
you were zelinski do you want to lose
the war
no of course not uh do you are in what
position are you right now well as you
already pointed out you're actively
trying to convince Americans to keep
putting the bill and you know
Republicans are off the table so you're
playing the Democrat game not
republicans in Congress well sure sure
you're the lagging indicator you know
that the the the the the the the the
American population and the way the Maga
base operates that you're not going to
be pandering to them although they
probably should be so let's think about
what it means to actually win a war does
it make sense if you are say like a a a
warrant there's a feudal Lords warring
in Japan and they're like you know I got
to take out my arrival let's walk to his
front Gates and then fight his guards or
does it make more sense to have a ninja
dress like a maiden or or a servant go
in in the middle of the night take out
the emperor and then flee by running out
the back door these are the tactics of
actual War Guerrilla tactics it's it's
impractical to think that the only thing
any military is going to do is March
down the field and then pull upset each
other if you want to win and you want
support false flags are tried and true
methods you used by governments
throughout history take the Gulf of
Tonkin for instance the U.S needs public
support to enter the Vietnam War so oh
no we're under attack our ship's been
attacked there's there's there's
absolutely brilliant reasons for
zielinski to uh uh false flag and
nuclear strike a small tactical
artillery strike maybe it's a lower
yield nuclear bomb and then say our
tests indicators a nuclear strike the
and they can make it seem reasonable but
there's a reason there is a reason why
you wouldn't do it and the reason why I
wouldn't do it is because he would lose
all support that's not true there was a
missile hit what was that shopping
district that got hit and they said it
was Russia turns out it was a it was
Australia that wasn't on purpose right
my point is blaming it on Russia was on
purpose I'm sure look I'm sure in the in
the in at the time they thought they
thought but you're making an assumption
it wasn't on purpose everything I'm
talking about is is exactly so what we
can say right now is that a Ukrainian
Missile hit Ukrainian civilians and they
blamed Russia for it we don't know that
it was a false flag the presumption is
it was an accident but we don't need to
make any assumptions about it at all all
we know is when you Ukrainian Missile
hit ukrainians they blamed Russia for it
look there's a there's a there's a
massive decree of difference between a a
a a a missile that went that went you're
assuming that you're right no no there
is a massive difference between a a
nuclear missile and Eric you have to
make the Assumption because you're
wishing for Goodwill but you have an
optimism bias and the normalcy in
optimism bias says the accident has to
be the case because nobody wants to
accept the the scenario that Ukraine
bombed their own citizens to to justify
ongoing uh engagement with Russia but
they did blame Russia for it was clearly
their mission yeah yeah but back back to
China I think this is an important point
because all look again we're looking at
the U.S interests what is best for us
interest and obviously degrading China
undeniably
um so look this this idea obviously
Russia Russia and China have been in
their each other's Orbits for
generations and and this is this is yes
this is maybe accelerated that to a
certain point and by the way you know
China is in a lot of trouble China is in
a crap load of trouble but there
for sure there's no question about it
but
um them spending money when we to to
fight a war is something that
isn't in their interest like they're
going to do it it's going to hurt them
we can afford it more than they can look
the reason we're talking about the
Taiwan conflict no no no I'm talking
about Ukraine well so actually both but
the reason why how do we win the Cold
War because we destroyed the Russian
economy because we outspent them right
this is not a game China certainly not
Russia Russia cannot expand this game at
all right they're just like they're just
they're just a a uh a uh a gas Depot
with with a nuclear missile on top of it
ah you sound like Ron DeSantis and John
McCain and Mitt Romney
no you meant that say as a cut on me
and a lot of people are like it's a
compliment right
um but the reality is that they both
China as well can ill afford to be in a
spending war with us in in Ukraine
that's it and B look again it goes back
the idea of Taiwan we don't we have a
much larger interest in Taiwan than
Ukraine right uh oh Clinton yeah and
there is no and China understands that
they're not stupid they understand it's
our interest and they they saw what we
did for Ukraine us and the Europeans did
for Ukraine with a much lower strategic
threshold than Taiwan they understand
this is not something we can f with okay
but they aren't Russia and the Taiwan
scenario does not present the same
opportunities that that uh the Dom bus
conflict does because you can move
weapons through Poland you've got all
these all these other this different
geography whereas Taiwan how do you get
into that fight is a real question and I
Usher them us how do we get into that
fight what are our bases Japan yeah
correct but but Australia immediately
they start making moves there against
those but what do we have in Australia
we have planes and ships that will be
taken out by Hypersonic missiles and we
have we do not have sufficient offenses
to those and China is ahead in
hypersonics they can hit a moving Target
we can't it seems that the United States
also I mean Australia is substantially
further away than you know
but look obviously yes I mean tactically
speaking these are all points that are
true but ultimately they understand that
we we wanted to we can bring weapons to
bear that would absolutely just blow
them out of the water they get that in
Taiwan yes we would not be able to
maintain air superiority over Taiwan
okay China May has Exquisite air defense
that is right there in their
neighborhood so when we get within 600
miles of Taiwan we get vanquished and
not just that is the implication that
our air support is to decimate the
civilian regions of Taiwan we we sure
there'd be there'd be a there'd be an
air you would want to get into an air
fight over Taiwan against the j-10s with
your f-35s the problem is you know can
you get them into the fight and not only
that let's talk about refueling I mean
you're talking about mainland China
right there we're moving ourselves
here's the let me ask you one question
sure do you think that China because of
the war in Ukraine do you think China is
less likely more likely or as likely to
I think it doesn't affect their decision
at all no I don't know fine I don't
agree let me tap it off really quick I'm
with you I think it makes them less
likely to invade but I also agree that
they don't really have a lot of
incentive to go to war right now but
yeah Chinese but what I'm concerned with
is what I don't agree with is that that
it's a zero-sum game that if if Russia
loses we win or vice versa I think there
are situations where we could both win
kind of like I don't disagree with that
um like I see the the Grand Republic of
China the Russian Federation in the
United States all working together to
defend you to the world basically red
white and blue together
um but it so I think that the Russia
like the United States took Libya and it
took Iraq now the the Russians are
trying to take eastern Ukraine then the
Chinese are going to want to take Taiwan
let's just call it after that yeah the
Russians kind of took Syria
you know the Chinese have taken the
South China Sea yeah so like we can talk
about we can talk about the Soviet Union
Afghanistan we can talk about the Geneva
conventions come on man war is war and
War doesn't stop because it's like hey
everyone we're gonna call it right here
it's something we shouldn't have
technically even occupied or or uh uh
annexed Hawaii based on the art on the
arguments yeah I think a lot of the the
crazy aggressive Conquest that we're
seeing as a result of the United States
taking Libya and Iraq personally
but that is overly simplistic Libya and
Iraq it all extends well before this I
mean this stuff's been going on for a
hundreds are we talking about Libya the
US moved in there with global Osprey
Solutions Sydney Blumenthal and Hillary
they killed Gaddafi and took it
basically we're gonna go to Arms
manufacturing we're gonna go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com we have a members only show
coming up after we wrap this one in
about 18 or so minutes sorry we didn't
get to Super chats earlier but um I want
to be clear I'm not sure Matt are you
able to stick around for them I gotta
travel all the way back to Washington
not this budget sorted out yeah no do
your thing and I just want I I just want
to make sure we're not telling everybody
you'll be here if you do have to run
back to I think I gotta run no problemo
man got a country to run man I know I
know I got enough this phone is this bet
as Ben let's read some super chats while
we're here maybe we'll get some
questions for you okay RJ mcdougelheim
says winner winner chicken dinner that's
right you had the first Super Chat and
then asks will Matt promise to let the
government shut down with a laughing
emoji no my goal is to get single
subject spending bills to pass them to
cut spending secure the border and and
Bank some wins for our people so if you
sign some of those there's a situation
where only some of the government shuts
down yeah you can have a partial
shutdown we've had those before
right on well let's uh let's grab some
more Raymond g Stanley Jr says Mr Gates
excellent speech one year after McCarthy
played you all to get himself the
speaker seat he proved himself
untrustworthy will you please kick
McCarthy to the curb and take over house
Speaker well I uh have no interesting
house Speaker I also would never be
elected because I don't have a the
requisite followers uh at all but I I
could tell you that uh McCarthy must
either come into compliance with the
deal he made in January he must do so
very quickly or there will be a motion
to vacate and a lot of that is spending
and some of it is like I want to vote on
federal term limits I want to vote on a
federal balance budget even though I
know that those things are going to fail
and then he promised to release the
January 6 tapes and has not done that
and I want to see that occurs the uh the
uh resolution the the resolution that
was found in the bathroom
to I'll try to be more careful in the
future so is that yours or what oh we
had a few drafts that uh
were in a folder and I don't believe it
was an accident
I'm I'm sorry I'm so sorry you can't buy
into my temporary journalist finds the
resolution to boot McCarthy and we all
we we all smiled that as for why Kevin
hasn't released the tapes the j6 tapes
is that just because people behind the
scenes have been like Hey Kevin you
better not do it or is it just his
purview or what what's going on well I
think he believes he fulfilled that
commitment by allowing Tucker Carlson
and a few other journalists access to a
terminal to make a few clips and leave
but that's a very different promise than
the one that he made and we want to draw
him into compliance
and then uh what's a vote to kick him
out look like well here's the thing I
mean if if we had about you know 20 30
however many Republicans thought he
should go then his fate would hang in
the hands of the Democrats and if I
filed a motion to vacate it would
immediately be subject to a motion to
table my motion and Democrats could all
choose to vote present on that and then
McCarthy would Prevail the motion of
vacate would be tabled and he would be
working for the Democrats at their women
at their will you think we should have
him on the show do you think he'd be
interested in coming on I think you
should absolutely invite him let's uh
read the Steve Jones says why on Earth
would Matt Gates want to fund DHS to
keep using taxpayer dollars to fund the
persecution of conservatives by the FBI
BLM FEMA you've got to be kidding please
justify why we should support that well
my first justification would be that the
FBI doesn't reside within DHS uh the
second would be DHS is Customs and
Border Patrol it's also ice those are
actually two entities that are in DHS
and I'm for those actually and I don't
want our border patrol to not be funded
now the reason I want a single subject
review of the DHS bill is that you can
go in there and excise the entities like
sisa and others that are involved in the
censorship industrial complex
Adrian horta Martinez says Tim my pocket
will allow another Super Chat until next
month's check sorry locals here in
Montgomery are tired of Greg Abbott
doing nothing some are saying they want
to go to the Border themselves they feel
our leaders are spitting on them people
are beginning to snap yeah there's that
story of the guy I think it was Arizona
the illegal immigrants were going onto
his property and then he was defending
his property I don't know exactly what
the details were but he he's allegedly
shot and killed a guy got arrested for
it people are starting to are getting
worried about what's going on with the
immigration crisis I get I mean I look I
don't support that but right I get it I
mean I get there they're they're seeing
people come across and they're seeing
their their elected government officials
that they pay taxes for doing nothing
800 800 soldiers isn't that is that is
that meant to be a joke is that meant to
be an Fu to us it sounds like it it's a
virtue signal to try to pacify a lot of
these liberal politicians that are now
enduring the consequences of becoming a
sanctuary I think a week a day of Crisis
is like a week of of peaceful living or
months of peaceful living what you go
through when you're in a crisis in one
day is like people if they're not there
and they don't aren't thinking about it
then it's like oh well in three days
we'll get the bill passed and then maybe
next week we'll census the people on the
ground are like it's like telling
someone who's in a burning building let
me get a resolution passed send the fire
department down and they're like no just
send the fire department down you're
like well we gotta have a bill we'll
discuss it and maybe it won't get out
let me be straight with you there's no
way to secure the Border if we don't
control the White House and the
administration you can pass any law you
want we got enough damn laws on the
books with the laws we have now you
could secure that border and you can Pat
you could do whatever you want they
ignore the law they don't and or they'll
write some new memo clarifying or
interpreting and then that will have the
force of law so it is necessary but not
sufficient to ensure that you have the
right statutes in place but right now
it's a matter of willpower and this
Administration wants to will these
people into the country and they don't
want any barrier that one gamer says
someone should propose a bill to disband
the ATF and turn the buildings into
liquor stores Herrera Texas 23 let's go
Brandon greetings from Los Angeles
California
I have a bill to abolish the ATF I think
there's no function of the ATF that
cannot be done by the Federal Marshals
or frankly a lot of state law
enforcement and you want to talk about
some of the most vicious and cruel
enforcement done by an agency that
cannot even fulfill its own basic
Mission I mean the ATF had their own gun
Locker robbed the ATF right no way yes
and they had they had a uh a
circumcision they were keeping over a
quarter of a million records illegally
that they were maintaining in a database
so it's a it's not a well-run agency and
should be subject to some of the I think
strictest review and where did let's go
Brandon go can we bring that back yeah
so well Brandon Herrera in Texas they're
saying it he's running for congress
great guy running against Tony Gonzalez
Brandon Herrera is a fine American so
people are saying let's go Brandon in a
positive way for Brandon Herrera so it's
it's come back I guess I missed that
Nuance yeah it's come back and now
they're excited for Brandon well he's
he's a he's the AK guy and he's running
against a Republican who voted for red
flag laws and if you want to talk about
one of the most Insidious like features
of what Republicans have allowed it's
this kind of tattle on your neighbor red
flag law oh his structure yeah Brandon
would be fantastic plus he's uh he's
building the ak-50 and I asked him I was
like is it going to be fully automatic
and he's like well I don't know if you
want something like that like okay but
yeah it probably will be so you know 50
BMG AK-47 full you build out without a
patent well he's they've got all the
licenses and all that stuff so yeah yeah
yeah so they're they're they're building
it it's an impractical device it's
ridiculous there's a there's a player on
the Lakers whose initials are AK and his
number is uh is uh I'm sorry AR as and
uh but they won't they won't use their
numbers 15 so they won't use the AR-15
oh wow Austin Reeves yeah yeah uh we'll
see well that was uh Anthony Richardson
was number 15 at the University of
Florida and he was AR-15 I I asked the
Lakers announcers a buddy of mine is
like could you do that
because it's Austin Reeves by the way
he's like the least like a yeah 15 guy
yes but Andrew carolenko was AK-47 they
they called him that all right we got uh
Eli McInnis says can you please ask
Congressman Gates about the Eglin UAP he
was briefed on and and his presence at
the uip hearing in the hoc it's my
birthday come on man spin the UFO
Crossland so uh can you talk about the
uip stuff or is it classified or what
well what I can tell you is that you
know I've seen things uh that there is
no U.S capability aligned to and we are
unaware of any foreign capability that's
aligned to we had a circumstance at
Eglin Air Force Base where during a test
mission our Pilots encountered four
aircraft that were in formation they
were not supposed to be any aircraft
there because it had been cleared out
for this particular weapons test so
someone went to go check it out and they
were amazingly able to click a photo of
it even though as they got close to it
all of the radar systems all the um uh
the whole dash just went absolutely out
and uh but he got this this one photo on
on one of his Fleer lenses I saw it I
have been pushing to get it out and uh
the hope is that we can get a subpoena
to get some of these Witnesses in to
give them immunity because right now you
got a lot of folks with information
that want to come forward but they're
deeply concerned that if they provide it
that they could be subjected to
different types of retaliation and so if
you get people kind of a friendly
subpoena it can immunize them to to come
forward I think it's I think it's likely
just Black Operations military
I mean I would say that but I have been
on like the committee that oversees
DARPA for seven years I have a pretty
clear understanding of the stuff we're
doing and the stuff we're not and that's
very positive I think they're lying to
you I mean I don't know if the Chinese
have developed a new technology that
they're utilizing out of Cuba that ended
up over the gulf that that we were not
aware of I don't know if we've got some
programs that maybe are not you know
fully briefed to Congress
yeah I think it might be talking plasma
are you familiar with it but take lasers
and they triangulate into a point in the
sky or they hit all these lasers at once
they create a ball of plasma that they
can move around on radar looks like a
craft and uh they can project sound
through it but dude it's shutting
shutting down radar and other
electronics yeah when you would get
close to italic and also where I saw the
heat signatures did not make a lot of
sense from a propulsion state it could
it could but it also could be uh it
could be it could be laser Vapor it
could be it could be uh could be private
sector right yep usually those private
sector uh things that that were joint
ventured on we have some understanding
and they don't breach your airspace
during your military tests right make
sure you guys go deep on talking plasma
because if there's a false flag Alien
Invasion they'll use that stuff to trick
people with hearing things you're just
you're basically just making a reference
project blue beans zelinsky so let's
give to the false flag alien false flag
I hear is going to be the big one is
going to be an alien false flag but now
that we're talking about it maybe it
won't be but uh the what you're
discussing is probably particularly
rudimentary three just have General
lasers military dot yeah military.com I
think it is talking about that's
rudimentary I mean you could
theoretically create Holograms using
multiple different lasers to craft an
image when the lasers intersect it makes
an appearance of something in the sky
and you can move it at the speed of
light by shifting lasers around here
it's just it's just it's Vegas light
magic and they'll do that with actual
drones high-tech drones that we probably
don't have access to and they'll do both
and people be like but I saw a craft but
on radar there's no way it could have
moved like that and you're like well
it's because it's light
because I don't know why radar would
pick up the light though huh could have
been that uh because that sounds that
sounds actually like the most plausible
thing I've ever heard so this wasn't
something that was moving at a high rate
of speed and so uh those those
capabilities were not reflected in in
the image I saw it was this was more
metallic horrible
orb which makes sense if it's a ball of
plasma would look like an orb did it
move not like an actual jettison craft
but like something hold on talking
talking plasma or any kind of laser uh
projection
does it have to move it can be still and
it can zip around and stop and start
because you can disappear and reappear
somewhere it's a laser pointer all it is
is when you point the laser pointer at
the wall that's that's that's
effectively one dimensional it's a point
if you take several different lasers
where they intersect the point will be
visible in three-dimensional space and
you just move the lasers around it's
they do this in Vegas when you go watch
light shows the guy will have the laser
in his hand and he's spinning it it
looks like he's flipping a lace if you
could pulse it off and on fast enough in
different locations you could make it
look like it's moving like lasers
yeah but you if you can make it
disappear and reappear really quick too
it'll it'll it'll give the illusion of
movement but it could give really weird
um I still just think that the the
Occam's Rage or simple solution is the
Manhattan Project was a secret you know
project not no one really knew what was
going on very few people did what we're
likely experiencing is Black Operations
or private sector military technology
and I'm willing to believe they don't
brief Congress on these things you get
you get good service level stuff and
then yeah about it was that Matt would
know about it I mean even if I didn't
know about it when I saw the image and
then ran it through the catalog of the
stuff we do and it didn't match anything
right yo I wonder what kind of meta
materials they're working on cermat
lightweight drone craft that can go
underwater and out into deep space and
one jaunt it's uh you know we we are
absolutely moving to the time where the
words are going to be fought by our our
space robots against airspace robots all
kind of directed by AI
and and once you can once you can kind
of use overlay that with Quantum you
know you're able to get get a lot more
output out of that yeah I want to take a
bunch of drones as military industrial
complex future 2.0 where we build
billion drones we onboard AI on all
these drones we let them fly around our
pilots and Target us as if they're
shooting but they just have ai on there
and then after we get done with the
sortie battle we can uh look at the AI
we'll tell us how we could have done it
better and it can train us how to fight
drone swarms then eventually we'll use a
laser lock the problem is on some of the
tests that we do they they they don't
always listen you know you you give it
an objective where certain targets are
worth certain points we had a we had a
matter where we sent out some therefore
sent out some drones and uh there was a
malfunction so the test wasn't going to
work so it recalled all the drones and
not all of them came back because they
said no I have to go earn these points
let's read this one we got uh Terence
Max's I was a public affairs officer for
the Canadians Ukrainian training mission
in the UK the lies I had to tell about
how well the training was going was
brutal those poor guys don't send a
chance with five weeks of training
now as a sad reality man we've all seen
those videos of the of the US trying to
train the people in Iraq and they can't
do jumping jacks or they're not called
jumping jacks they're calling someone
else but well we're great at training
people in Africa we've trained all the
recent coup leaders oh wow they're doing
pretty well yeah we're so if you look at
the last like nine coups in Africa all
of them have had people involved that
we've trained so is the Wagner group
yeah yeah I mean you know it's it's
unfortunately a part of great power
competition in Africa now the Wagner is
in a different state of affairs these
days than it used to be it's sort of
been resorbed into the Russian military
ICU says I'm a disabled veteran will
this shutdown make me lose my house how
much do I have to give for this country
well I think that would depend on the
circumstances of the house and how
you're paying for it but yeah I mean
there will be there will be disruptions
uh throughout the Enterprise of
government if you are reliant on
government for anything whether it's
your benefits or getting the mail there
will be some impact now Social Security
and VA benefits
are deemed essential and so that they
it's not that we are giving up on those
things but there are ancillary effects
to any shutdown that's why I'm not I'm
not a cheerleader for shutdowns I'm not
I I think that's nihilist I think that's
really uh not gonna make quality of life
better for the people who are my boss I
agree but I would also say this if your
position is yeah let's get funding for
for disabled veterans and everything
they need we'll get the single subject
built right now done today if it is the
rest of Congress that rejects that
because they want the Omnibus they're
the ones blocking the single bill that
gets the person and the good news is the
first single subject bill that we did
pass was military construction and VA
benefits so if we were to go into a
shutdown on October 1st there is a
device for the Senate to pick up and
even if the Senate didn't have all of
our views on how VA ought to be
administered we could go and Conference
and negotiate that issue unfortunately
Chuck Schumer's mentality is It's All or
Nothing on everything because that's
what centralizes power most what's the
point of getting power in leadership
positions if you can't use them to
centralize power help your friends and
hurt your enemies yeah
Weber Jay says how does China buying
land in other countries work in war they
can say no no our land can't plant here
maybe I'm stupid but I don't get how
that works well cash mostly I mean there
are more Chinese with like the
equivalent of two million dollars
American Cash liquidity then there are
total Canadians wow and when you tell
them that there's like stuff you can buy
and is yours forever
it is a very appealing Prospect yeah in
China they lease it wasn't like right
you can't own stuff you can't own land
in China you you just can it can
participate in a leasehold interest so
you start telling people with that kind
of liquidity that stuff can be yours
forever and they are they have become
major reels Real Estate Investors now I
don't I don't think you should be able
to pollute the skies in Shanghai and
then buy the penthouses in Manhattan I
don't think we should allow like the
ill-gotten gains through devaluation of
currency through terrible environmental
practices to result in literally getting
the Great American asset class even more
Insidious than that is they they loan
money these countries and they say at
massive interest rates knowing they're
going to default and part of the
contract is if you default on this
airport You're Building we're going to
own the airport and the land around it
Yep they're black and by the way if they
show up with with you know suitcases
full of cash and hookers on the front
end those bribes work and a lot of these
leaders they take those deals are
leaving and so so that's like the how
the great power competition is where
working Russia's value proposition is
regime preservation they say like if
you're in trouble Maduro or Assad like
we can bring muscle and keep you in
power the Chinese say we'll give you
upfront cash now to be able to gore you
later and what we say is we'd like to
know more about your pride month policy
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
share the show with your friends if you
really do like it but more importantly
head over to timcast.com click join us
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up in a few
minutes and we will actually take your
calls as uh as members of timcast you
will join our Discord server and get to
hang out with like-minded individuals
they host a before show a pre-show they
host an after after show so it really is
cool if you're interested in making
music getting involved in projects the
timcast Discord is really really awesome
you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me personally at timcast
Matt do you want to shout anything out I
really appreciate you having me on
there's something about the Tim cast
audience man like the Fox News audience
when they see me it's just unadulterated
exuberance the Newsmax audience they're
like they think you're like part of a
special Club because they've seen you on
Newsmax the War Room ban an audience
they just want to kind of pound their
chest and growl at you but the Tim cast
audience whenever they see me it can be
an airport a gas station they want to
sit down and talk to you for at least
half an hour hour about what is on their
mind at that precise moment and your
deepest thoughts about it so brother you
have you have really uh developed a a
trust with a an audience that cuts
across every age group every ethnic
group every class and it is a really
cool thing to be a part of a lot of them
are smarter than all of us all the
people here in this room and often will
say something and they correct Us in the
chat and then we'll be back oh look at
that that's why I love the supercheck
it's too far for me though yeah but it's
great we do a show and I see someone
super Chan be like here's the fact or
we'll be like we don't know this I think
the chat will get it for us and then the
the viewers like will give us the
information to help make the show it's
awesome yeah uh did you want to mention
anything like social media or oh yeah at
Mac eights at rep mac8s everywhere on
the internet and figure out how we're
gonna either fund or shut down the
government right on Ami you want
anything out thanks for having me on
absolutely dude great to have you I know
tell everybody where to find these
videos you've been previewing you've
froth up the audience for the next video
you can follow me on YouTube and at
homie Horowitz for all the socials right
on man great to see you guys awesome I'm
Ian Crossland you guys follow me Ian
Crossing anywhere everywhere good
talking let's go deeper next time as
always catch you guys later
that was wild wow
um great conversation thank you both for
coming on I'm yeah just so fascinating
and entertaining and I thoroughly
enjoyed it um
anyway I'm Carter Banks simply they make
music you can follow me at Carter banks
on Twitter Carter banks4l on Instagram
and Tim cast music right on records all
right everybody we'll see you all over
at timcast.com in a few minutes thanks
for hanging out